greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now once introduced
23andme it's a DNA testing service that
could offer you insights into ancestry
health wellness and traits the 23andme
health and ancestry service includes
reports on how your DNA can influence
your weight sleep quality caffeine
intake sense of taste
whether you're likely to be lactose
intolerance and a lot lot more and it's
easy to do you simply spit into the tool
provided in your 23andme kit and you
mail it to it we are saliva sample back
to the lab to be analyzed do me a favor
order your 23andme health and ancestry
kit at 23andme comm slash Church that's
23andme comm slash shirts that's the
number 23andme calm slash Church find
out what's crack-a-lackin' with you the
church also wants to give a shout out to
my people my book e.com and [ __ ]
football is back and it's in full effect
and listen why have all these [ __ ]
locks if you're not gonna pick a winner
and get paid this is one full Joey comes
in with my bookie right now today you
should already open up a [ __ ] account
why because my bookie is the only one
service I recommend to the church family
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my book you know why cuz you win
and you get paid no [ __ ] drama no
tiptop mcglue
no I gotta wait til Thursday and meet
the guy at the [ __ ] diner [ __ ] him
my bookie is the way to go what do you
do is do this why [ __ ] around you want
to make some givers for the holiday
season join now and my bookie will match
your deposit dollar for dollar you're
sitting there going Joey what are you
talking about don't match your deposit
dollar for dollar use promo code Church
CH you are ch ch you are r CH grab a pen
CH you are CH did you get that right to
activate your offer visit my bookie
online today and don't forget to use the
promo code Church again CH you are CH
when you create your account could you
claim up to a thousand and free play
my bookie you play you win you get paid
Creek that [ __ ] mule leakers we're
not [ __ ] around on Monday more that's
as good as it [ __ ] gets I got
Sammy trips in this [ __ ] holla I
got any Bravo on this [ __ ]
I got tinfoil I got the [ __ ]
the original Juju's happy Rosh Hashanah
to you and your family thank you and all
the Jewish community at swalot church
happy Rosh Hashanah you got another year
to be a bad mother [ __ ] Jew and don't
let me see you driving a Volkswagen a
little hate your heart to those [ __ ]
Germans just a little bit what's going
on tinfoil family yelling it did we're
killing it thanks for having me on gangs
have nuts on do please get on the mark I
want you to look good yeah we go number
20 years ago between somebody tell you
get on the mark yeah you looked around
like you didn't know what the [ __ ] they
were talking about that way isn't that
white tape on the ground
yes get on your mark like they'll tell
you the stand-in and they put like a
body double in there for two minutes
they put tape around you and they'll pay
this Stephan to the mark and you keep
[ __ ] steppin I didn't know what that
meant when I did back BASEketball
oh you didn't know what the mark man I
had no idea
Wow can you imagine being another [ __ ]
what I did the pilot for CBS like I was
so bad like you ever do a job and every
day your lines got shorter and shorter
my stars I have like eight pages then I
went to five then I went to two really
then I went to one line and then I went
to like a half a line like what's it
gonna be like inspired you go what the
[ __ ] going on did you go no cuz I knew
I and I was green around the gills but
you still had enough big bucket I didn't
book it they saw me on stage oh and they
booked me for a CBS pilot off a [ __ ]
stage in Seattle that's and when I went
on the maze read you know when you go to
a table read you can fake the funk a
little bit but once I got on the set I
didn't know what I was doing I didn't
say nothin Oh buddy that boot the
commercial but I booked bass ketball and
I was basically a cokehead a bass
ketball like that that's all I did every
night and I never forget them go and
step up to mark cause you had a roller
skate in
remember my seen yet the rollers came in
by that part
I'd robbed all the roller skates with no
Roma skates that was size 11 they were
all over at the Swiss Chalet what'd you
do with all the roller skates I would
take the road they would put United when
you shoot a movie yeah but your clothes
a little yeah they put my clothes the
room and I park this is when 9/11 pre
9/11 so you knew the guard so they knew
you from the Comedy Store some they let
me park right next to the trailer every
day I don't know how I did it
looking back that's how [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] I was and I would take my
roller skates and I stopped it like this
Swiss Chalet offer like a Cobra City one
of those they used to have like one down
there like and I went in and I was
pulling like the old scam from the old
days how you doing my uncle gave me a
payroll case they don't fit and they
looked up they're like we'll give you
one 49th oh so I knew I would get $150 a
day if I brought in roller skis oh my
god so every time I would work I would
steal somebody's roller skates from the
set and then I just started going there
was no cameras then I would just go into
the truck where the roller skates are
and I would just take a box of
rollerskates
if somebody would ask me why do you have
size 14 and I want to you know who
Jack's from roller skates max roller
skates
bro by the time I shot my scene like I
was like on the third week of showing up
and not shooting I would just go there
basically to watch Jenny McCarthy okay
you know what I watched those two guys
so hot would the two guys that wrote
that I had no idea what I was working
with people were kissing my ass you know
bringing me sodas I didn't know and then
I'll never forget that I I went out and
I got [ __ ] up because I kept going in
there just to hang out oh you were like
I was shooting a movie but there was
make me coming at 8:00 and it'd be eight
o'clock at night Nick oh you'd gone
there and I go what am I gonna shoot me
oh oh that effect immersed so the night
I stayed out till 7:00 snorting coke by
the Hollywood Sun with some crazy people
after the store and I had to go all the
way to the forum great that's what yeah
yeah yeah the forum yeah
and when I got there they were like your
first scene up like I've been snorting
coke till 6:00
dude it's 7:30 they called me in for
rehearsal oh my and guys fell apart at
the seams first of all they couldn't
find roller skates on me like way your
roller skate something like that Swiss
Chalet I'm like I don't know what we're
on skates are everyday my reel of skates
I'm missing so I got out of the roller
skate so if you watch the scene I have
to skate up like I'm roller skate and
then he says a scene a line I say a line
and we both skate away
but you didn't have skates no what a
great actor you were cuz I never knew
that so when we went up to each other
like dog I was going back to back and
the guys going cut it took maybe four
hours to shoot that that's how bad I was
funny when they said cut you could tell
like when I walked away they all through
their [ __ ] speakers on the phone like
that's how bad I was and when I got the
call to how many guests do you want to
come bring to the premiere I was like
who is this ha ha this is Johnny Bananas
from paramount or whatever company who
did the movie we want to know how many
people P bring into the premiere I go
from me or what and they're like bass
ketball cuz when I left there like they
cut me that's how bad I was like that's
how crazy bad I was I don't remember the
movie did you make it in the movie
yes did see would you just go all over
town selling roller skates Swiss Chalet
it's gotta be like ways that was played
again sports oh yeah yeah play again
sports would give me like 75 bucks they
don't give a [ __ ] of a brand-new roller
skating your [ __ ] was two packages from
Chewie right got that 24 the bartender
the drink and how you do bad yeah you
need 60 bucks yeah two packages from
sure we want to do there and what to do
later around with some crazy chick knee
bump into and one that and then 20 bucks
to tip hock that's your philosophy we
don't what wonderful the craziest party
I've ever been to
was it was a Halloween party by the
South Park guys
Matt stone yeah marker dude oh they're
brilliant those too I got invited that
boys this twenty years they're still on
TV buddy dude let's see it
I look this is it for sure undergoing a
life-saving operation tonight fancy of
course the singing and support me this
brave Louisville and his hero Joe Cooper
promising to hit three home runs a
promise that could mean the difference
between life and death assistance award
[Applause]
and the home run certainly getting ready
to take him suppose bro that's after
word all night
that's snorting coke from 11:30 so final
5:45 I lived in off of Riverside and
right in Studio City with the person I
was doing coke with dropped me off I
went upstairs and lay down in bed with
my girlfriend I still remember her
getting up going how did you sleep last
night I was at war it was a great night
last night the next II know she's
driving me to the forum in traffic and I
get there like you're the first one up
you know their first movie Orgazmo did
you ever see yeah that was the first
movie that the villain in it
what his name was in the movie but it's
like a karate guy and there's like a
karate scene but that guy went to
jujitsu with me at John jocks we got our
black belts
really his name is David Dunn and he was
in the movie and we were we were pretty
good friends and this is like 1998 he
calls me up on Halloween dance 1990 and
goes dude do you want to go to South
Park Halloween party oh my god [ __ ] I
goes do they gave me two invites and and
he was gonna bring a chick and he had
one extra ticket because it's tonight
but you have to have a costume and I
didn't have a costume ready sighs so I
said [ __ ] it I went to I went to the
Halloween store on Hollywood Boulevard
you know that
I went in there and my plan was the only
thing I think of is to get a I had a
Chinese hat right one of them Chinese
hats because I went to Coachella and I
had that I go you know what I'll go to
this party as a Chinese guy with the
machine gun you know like Vietcong
so I went to the Halloween store I
couldn't find a machine gun
turns out they're illegal you can't have
machine gun my toy machine guns so that
[ __ ] up my idea like [ __ ] what could I
do now so I'm like walking around the
Halloween store and then I see those
Billy Bob fake teeth yeah and I looked
at that I thought [ __ ] hmm maybe I could
be a homeless dude I got those D and
then I had this idea I'm gonna be a
[ __ ] panhandler
homeless guy so I had the teeth [ __ ]
up billy-bob teeth I went to pick and
save that was on vine and and son said
it's gone now they just not right but
there was a pick and save there I went
there because I needed a like a like a
like a Bud Light you know I was like I'm
gonna get a so I found a Korres ice hat
oh so I found 12 bucks and I needed to
make it really dirty so I scraped it on
the ground had it all dirty I just
wanted to be a panhandler carotid teeth
or on [ __ ] eyes hat oh and then I'm my
neighbor he was a construction workers a
plumber so he had dirty nasty shirt so I
got one of his [ __ ] hella fied
stained shirts and I'm put on some dirty
jeans and I had these Reeboks from when
I used to dye carpet for a living
instead of cleaning the carpet you put
dye and it's it's like for people don't
want to buy new carpet you could dye
your [ __ ] carpet it doesn't really
work but I was in the industry and had
Reeboks they had like nine different
layers of dye on them and I took out the
I took off them the shoestrings and so I
had that and then I got a gigantic
crescent wrench and I just put her in my
back pocket and we're never gonna come
pick me up in like [ __ ] I'm a panhandler
[ __ ] I'm like this bum right so I
wanted to test it out so they show up
they pull up in my parking lot and I
told that I told David I go hey listen
I'm gonna come out with my my costume
don't tell you girl what's up I'm just
gonna try to scare so they pull up and
and I walk up and this
you know I just went up and started
asking for change like right up to the
car and she freaked out because she saw
the teeth you see 14 ha and I'm like I
look like a dirty pan amateur so if she
freaked out and I thought okay cool this
is gonna work so I go to this [ __ ]
party it's right there it's at the
Quixote studios next to where the Trader
Joe's easy on Santa Monica remember the
Trader Joe's on Santa Monica and my
gardener from where I tap Keenen Ivory
Wayans I yes you guys know that but I
tap them so there's that exactly so
there's a the Quixote studios that right
right so they had a [ __ ] party dude I
don't know how much money is this party
cost but these are like four gigantic
Studios gigantic four of them and each
room was one room we just had a hundred
couches you know and then the next room
but let me back up a little bit we show
up and I don't know which one is Trey
Parker and which one's Matt Stone Matt
so which was a little die fro matter
train Trey's the blonde haired okay so
the owner guy he's he's in like a Batman
like a superhero outfit it looks like
Batman but it has II on his chest he was
Captain II he was Captain II and on his
utility belt - do you have like [ __ ]
$10,000 worth the [ __ ] e really yes
right that's a great party oh dude it
was the greatest party I've ever been to
in my [ __ ] life
so we show up and everybody's everyone
that's you know superhero outfit a um
Dale Earnhardt outfit everyone's got
these outfits and everyone's walking
around going
cool outfit cool costume cool and then
when they would they would look at me
they'll be like scared they didn't say
[ __ ] to me that we are they wouldn't
even look me in the eye like [ __ ] these
guys are really everybody was scared of
they're like who brought the homeless
dude who but who got the homeless dude
in here so instantly I took like [ __ ]
two or three hits
dude I was flying IDs fake billy-bob
teeth
I had this gigantic crescent wrench and
I'm walking around every nobody thinks
it's a costume nobody's there everyone
thinks this is [ __ ] crazy for your
charity event like maze
some crazy panhandler or like some crazy
like handyman on the studios and one
rule like I said one gigantic studio was
a hundred couches for people to be on e
all [ __ ] up another room another
studio was all like like Arabian type
couches with a you know I don't even
know what the hell you would call it but
they're like um the couches on the
ground and they got all these uh like
mosquito nets and [ __ ] yeah they look
like but it looked like a Saudi Arabian
or whatever right and then another room
was a [ __ ] club with a DJ and on the
floor there was little rooms little
boots like porta-potties all over the
place would you go you could go make out
with chicks in these little porta potti
rooms they weren't porta-potties but
they this is the greates party yes it
was the greatest party ever so there was
a club with a DJ with all these
porta-potties people were dancing and
then you go to another studio couches
another studio couches on the floor
where you could lay down everyone
thought [ __ ] up right
it was [ __ ] nuts it was nuts so I'm
walking around scaring everybody I'm
having the time of my life just scared
because I go up to her I'd go up to
everybody and asking for change I just
wanted to ask I go you got some $0.50
and they'd be like uh maybe let me see
look people were [ __ ] giving me money
I was having so much [ __ ] fun
panhandling right yeah and then every
now and then I'd see this guy he's like
six foot five he had the [ __ ]
billy-bob teeth - big [ __ ] dude and
he had a wife beater and he was walking
around scaring people - and we would
cross paths and we'd look at each other
and were like are we doing the same [ __ ]
and then he would be gone and then I'd
be sweet panhandling I was just having
the time of my life panel and then I'd
see him again and then we bump into each
other again how much pies you ready and
I'm like and all of a sudden he was
[ __ ] up everybody there was [ __ ] up
on ecstasy and arm we were [ __ ] fried
out of and then all of a sudden we
bumped into each other and we just it
was like this weird [ __ ] connection
we had cuz we didn't even talk we didn't
have any regular conversations we would
just hate each other you know what I
mean we just hated each other and I
called security over and he had a Billy
Bob tea uh he had billy-bob teeth
and with a gold tooth I didn't have a
goal to his billy-bob teeth had a gold
tooth so we we would call security
I'll call security or me go what's going
on and go he has my go-to and and then
and then um and you're just no I go to
and I go no that's my go to and I pull
out I pull out the crescent wrench and
he opened his mouth he'd open his mouth
and like like those robots in Pirates of
Caribbean how they're all [ __ ]
they're all they look like [ __ ] I would
just we would just get into this robot
state we bring in the security and I'd
like want my goal to so I'm trying to
get my gold tooth back from him and he's
like this and I'm like down the security
I'm using the security it's like it's
it's all night humming it to ye are you
on at this place I've kept doing this
all night to security I kept calling
security I kept sir I kept asking them
to get my gold tooth from this
[ __ ] and eventually the security
threatened to kick us out if we just
kept we kept [ __ ] around you like
it's like okay the jokes over yes yes so
then we went to the dance floor we went
to the regular clearing your new buddy
we walk in you're going to take a piss
we walk in to the club and everyone's
dancing and me and him we look scary as
[ __ ] so we look like gangsters and we're
just what we are loving scaring people
we're having the greatest time scaring
the [ __ ] out of these people so when we
walk on the dance floor everybody clears
out everyone's dancing having a good
time and then everybody clears up and
we're walking around like we're gonna
[ __ ] some people up and at the height of
their fear all of a sudden we start
dancing like we're getting you are we
start dancing like we're gay on each
other people on what the [ __ ] is going
on and then we would stop and then we
would mad dog everybody and walk around
and just look at people and just scare
them and I'm like oh [ __ ] there's white
people from [ __ ] like actors and [ __ ]
like that in the industry scared as [ __ ]
of us we look scary and then the at the
height of that fear boom we start
dancing like we're gay on each other
it's like we're in West Hollywood are in
Mickey's and we just we're dancing we're
just trying to mind [ __ ] these people
you and so funny and then we would stop
and then good
and strong everybody so people didn't
know if we were gay or if we're gonna
kill them crazy part maybe you were gang
gonna kill them what's the craziest
party you have went to Hollywood how
long have you been out here I have been
out here for since what mm and what's
the craziest party you ever went out I
think the craziest part I ever went to
was when I worked at crunch way back in
the day I worked at crunch and like
those those people party dude like
people who work like the the trainer's
Pinkel [ __ ] hard in the paint bro
like they're incredibly good-looking
people and they party [ __ ] hard and
it's so funny cuz once why I always see
my old my old ecstasy dealer he books
commercials left and right I'm so proud
of him I'm like look at that look at
good old boy good book and [ __ ]
commercials but yeah I mean they went to
this huge house everybody on coke just
getting [ __ ] lit up everybody got
into parties up in the Hollywood Hills
and [ __ ] yeah you guys yeah hmm that was
the greatest part and that was 1998
yeah think about what was in twenty
eight when I went to that [ __ ] a
long time ago 20 years ago I used to go
to ah like Beacher's Madhouse in Vegas
that was crazy dude
crazy what year is that that I remember
that that was like 2002 maybe a premier
place to be even do come in the only
like Robert Kelley hey they like Robert
Kelley Steve I did well every time but
once and yet it but it was the greatest
party ever dude and it was like an
assault on your [ __ ] senses midgets
fire dancing like sword swallowing and
then you have to walk out and do
stand-up it was crazy need to be Alex
ah no dude I was sober then yeah so I
was like [ __ ] it you know I wasn't gonna
do it you've been to a party where you
were drugged up like crazy [ __ ] was born
ah like Illuminati style know what you
told me that I'm a mover having a comas
a conversation one time and you were
telling me that these dudes in Hollywood
take the viagra and they would mix it
with ecstasy and get a turkey
Easter and shoot the combination there
Anthony
I never heard of that I never only that
stuff at the store I am like I don't
know I don't know about parties with
that being the theme but people you know
when you do ecstasy MDMA you want to
[ __ ] really bad more than oh yeah more
than ever you want to [ __ ] for eight
hours but the problem is for guys it
could [ __ ] with your dick it basically
just you get limp dick but you want to
[ __ ] so much but you got limp dick but
then - yeah it's the worst but it does
but coke doesn't make you horny like mbm
oh yeah what I think makes me horny but
to my girlfriend you walk around women
love you somewhere it's you you wanna
you want to eat [ __ ] for five hours
straight your neck could be killing you
but you're like let's just keep let me
just keepin I never did all that like I
had so many my problems over coke so
what everybody was doing that yeah Pete
and everything else my philosophy was
why mess with it
I got enough problems on my own just
being me nevermind MDMA and pills not
like that and then one of the first
times I did ecstasy I was in Miami
it was a Sunday night there was a seven
o'clock show it was a Pablo [ __ ] aka
oh my brother god and he came up to me
and he does what I do the lead he goes
what's wrong with your tooth playing or
nothing
he was open your mouth you have
something that I definitely do ecstasy
in my oh my god Pablo Francisco and I
follow [ __ ] he's got the greatest
ecstasy bit ever Pablo Francisco use you
- dude that came out to see he came out
45 murder - yeah he gave me a card man
he's one of the greatest he was the
first time one of the great then the
second time was you guys remember Adrian
Shawshank the hot waitress um destroy
the blonde hippie chick yeah yeah yeah
one night million her days and we was
gonna go do crazy stuff and her
boyfriend showed up
oh so I went home fell asleep and got up
at 5:00 in the morning piss and I wasn't
full of things going and then the other
time I got arrested was I said I woke up
it was 1997 I woke up I was living with
Josh wolf in Seattle and he goes bro I
didn't do this ecstasy this weekend you
want it I go [ __ ] yeah I think it was a
Monday morning it had to be 11:00 in the
morning
11:00 in the morning you're doing by
myself just to go she said how the Apple
and I go to downtown Seattle my ex calls
me up and I go over there and I'm giving
her a stabbing awesome the cops are
knocking on the door and because it's
she got restraining I got each other and
she told the neighbor if you see Joey
Diaz called the police and neighbor saw
him he called the cops while I was
giving her stab and I'm and I hid under
the bed they drew their guns and the bed
was all down my from me breathing the
bed was going up and down so I cut out
from under the bed so here with the
police station with no shirt on like if
two o'clock burn it just rolling rolling
I like seeing their fingerprint them me
and I'm looking at his hands but to me
[ __ ] I had never done it like guys like
like I'd never been to those Hollywood I
never really did not really do I don't
know with Joe back in those days and Joe
hated that [ __ ] so how was always like
dude let's let's [ __ ] go to some
parties and Joe's like [ __ ] trash
people you know so I got I get when I
did go to those parties it was always
when I got asked to work it in some
weird way that's how I get into these
parties you know I like God I did a
bikini contest it was really funny at
the Key Club one time and this is when I
was drinking hard like hard and there
this one I got paid in free entering
tickets so I didn't care about money
they like Hey Dude here's ten drink
tickets boom and we're talking Jager
Bomb Jager Bomb Jack Daniels boom boom
boom hadn't really found Coke at that
moment but man I was so drunk so I start
the the bikini contest and this one
chick she wasn't the prettiest but she
had the will to win okay she goes out
and just boom just releases the monkey
to the
boom-boom-boom just shows everybody or
snatch crowd goes crazy right I'm so
shit-faced the the whole thing is rigged
it's like the owners girlfriend is in
the contest she's supposed to win the
whole thing she she the girl who showed
her [ __ ] is the number one I get handed
the list and it says number one I just
read the winner is number one and that's
the monkey that came out dude the crop
the owner went nuts
get on the [ __ ] out here she wasn't
supposed to win this other person was
supposed to and I'm like [ __ ] dude so I
feel like I'm floating I got I'm just
blackout drunk
they got me that bouncers his huge
bouncers walked me out right they they
put me in my car and I'm like okay I'm
just going to try to drive home man I'm
gonna try to [ __ ] go for it
I Drive I I go I literally go twenty
feet I get pulled over right cops I'm
like well tonight's the night right so
the cops fold they get me out to go so
what's going on because they could tell
something was on right so I'm said you
you wanna know the truth
and I go they oh yeah I go I told him
the [ __ ] story of the the [ __ ]
girl shown her monkey big [ __ ] I
thought she was gonna [ __ ] win they
said no I had to take the crown off the
girl who I thought one who showed
everybody her snatch and put it on the
guy's girlfriend who was the actual
winner girl this girls crying I'm
getting beat up and thrown out I tell
the cops that they put me back in my car
and they give me a police escort all the
way home that's probably one of the
crazy [ __ ] ever cuz you were honest I
just lied you what we're here the other
day I mentioned the Eddie Bravo cuz I
was out with Eddie used to make me laugh
man and he has always made me laugh but
he has the same probably two guys that I
had thought one was stinky because he
was Italian like if you saw him he was
Italian but once he had three drinks he
hasn't but his grandmother was American
Indian we just had another friend to
hang up with his name was Jimmy Buerkle
the guy was personality like a great
personality great guy but brother when
he drank
why he was really smart but he drank his
eyebrow and throw up and he would start
smoking cigarettes and act differently
so we used to call the mark he'd decide
haha crazy like whatever he drank he'd
just go crazy but you know I met any
couple times and we went out and there
was three particular times it was one
night Austin will view me and Joe when I
have to do a show and then we went to
Fogo the child and you started drinking
that foe got a [ __ ] child
and then they anyone think you forgot
what he was staying in his hotel and he
went to the wrong hotel so they chased
you down the street and you fouling you
slid on your knees and you remember that
[ __ ] come on
though you used to have some good when
you were single and I admire people who
have a life and I admire people like
they we can hang out with people were
cool people I'm going to hang out with
Taye Diggs and you know I like people
who go out make some happen by
themselves because that's always me I
know how to [ __ ] get an Eightball
to join a bird bar by myself
yeah next thing you know by myself all
the time guys come out with me and I'm
like okay you can come but you got to
drive your own car because I'm not gonna
drive you home
right like you got a I mean I I go by my
I how it between 88 and 92 I went out by
myself and that's your best bet
yeah as a single man you gettin those
clicks that we're doing this Vegas that
sucks I always believed to start a
little neighborhood bar and if you don't
the neighborhood bar isn't good then you
go to the big boy more people for 910 a
neighbor drunk and everything you keep
it simple a little Mary Cheng she's
unhappy husband just at the second job
but she tried to do a line of coke
you got that [ __ ] it's over you got a
blow job so I'm saying like and he
always had the classic Eddie Bravo story
is when he went to Germany with Rogen oh
yeah and he [ __ ] woke up in the
middle of the night and realized he was
late breaking down already
man there's there's there's so much to
that
Germany story Joe wrote a blog about it
it was so crazy Joe wrote it cuz he was
[ __ ] mad at me Oh what year was this
this is he was smoking already 2007-2008
I think it was the first time it was the
first time the UFC went to Germany and
it was a Cologne Germany and man after
the UFC which is a Saturday night
they're generally Sunday morning is the
flight home Brian and when we're
overseas I like because we went to
England a bunch of times and we would do
this in England in England after the UFC
don't go to sleep party all night right
into you know and then when you get on
that plane the next morning you past
asleep for [ __ ] 10 hours didn't you
wake up you're in LA it's the perfect
system right
it sucks being awake you know on a
10-hour flaw it's the worst
dude it's torture so um you you want to
stay up and party just so that you could
just sleep through that flight so a
party all goddamn night Joe Dean come
out but I went out I don't know who the
[ __ ] I was with it was it was an insane
night in Cologne Germany and I they say
Germany is amazing I got back to the
hotel probably 7:00 in the morning or
something and our car me and Joe's card
it was Joe's collar and I'm just like
tagging along with Joe you know man
who's picking us up like at 9:00 I get
back at 7:00 right I walk in to the
hotel and I'm a job
I'm completely out I'm completely I
don't I don't remember any of this this
is just I must have been cuz Joe saw me
Joe some he was in the lobby and he's
like and I went up to my room I tried to
pack I guess you know and I have a
certain way of packing I you know
everyone's got a little system right in
my backpack my laptop right and yeah I
got my toiletries in my backpack and in
my in my suitcase got all my clothes and
just basically all my private so I don't
remember I don't remember getting back
to the hotel I don't I don't remember I
don't remember Joe saying we're leaving
in two hours I remember and you just
went hard you know what I remember all I
remember is it's black and then my
phone's going off my phone's going off
and I wake up and I'm in the back seat
of some car going like a on the Autobahn
racing to the airport and I don't know
what the where the [ __ ] I'm at and I
look at my phone this is Joe Rogan on it
said actually Josh
it says Josh and Mike and I answered it
and he said and I asked driver I go
where the [ __ ] are we going he turns
back goes we're going to the airport
Mike [ __ ] then Joe calls again I'm
like [ __ ] and I just send it to
voicemail I'm like holy [ __ ] I didn't
and then I opened up my backpack my one
shoe is in my backpack no laptop just
one shoe and my butt and then I open up
the suitcase in my laptops in the
[ __ ] suitcase so I feel like oh my
god what the where the [ __ ] yeah dude
I've had the only night show called
again and goes dude you took my car and
I don't remember anything so I must have
just tried to pack like in a yeah in a
zombie State yeah I packed in a zombie
State and I went out and that driver
must have said Joe Rogan and I must have
said yes and he goes jumper on him and
he just put me in the car and we drove
away and then you know I don't know
Murray knew that I came to life it's
like the beginning of a movie like you
know just black
ruining your phone and all of a sudden
boom my eyes open you're like reality
call me no I've no read the last thing I
remember I'm doing shot to some bar in
Germany I don't remember getting home I
don't remember going to the hotel
packing and then getting in the car I
woke up in the backseat of some [ __ ]
car on the Autobahn racing to the
airport so I get to the airport
right so Joe takes a taxi he jumps in a
taxi and he is so mad yeah not talk to
me he didn't talk to me the whole time
at the airport although the whole flight
back were sitting next to each other
like first class and he didn't say a
word to me he was mad probably for about
a week and then he wrote a blog and then
he realized okay you know it's over
we should he should kind of like you
know laugh about it so then it became a
joke to him but he was [ __ ] furious
dude but there's a blog somewhere on the
internet I don't know I don't know that
it's got to still be up there but it's
about that story you trip senior you
know I was thinking about this I did a
show on Maz Jobrani in Washington DC
when it was the accident it wasn't the
accident of evil it was uh what was it
before that
Rabia night and I was so blessed to get
in at The Comedy Store because she
needed middle eastern comics so I kind
of fudged the math and got in on it
right so we were doing some tours he
took me to do a gig with him in
Washington DC in this giant theater and
I got the open forum and man Maz Jobrani
puts on a show do the show and his crowd
is fawn dude his crowd is fun so we go
there and ah you know so it's in
Washington DC and you know I'm a
conspiracy theorist so you know
everybody's around talking politics and
I'm just like sowing seeds of doubt and
I [ __ ] love it right well there's
this one blonde chick and she just
starts going in at me hard in at me
heart and we're arguing the whole time
boom boom boom boom boom and then
something happens
ends up drinking i black out I wake up
in my hotel room my clothes are ripped
everything's am I in my [ __ ]
tell room is smashed my phone my
computer's broken my suits are all
ripped and I go what the [ __ ] am I go I
don't know you [ __ ] started making
out with that blonde chick and then you
guys took off and and that was the end
of the [ __ ] I have no clue I mean I mean
blood on the wall I don't [ __ ] know
what the [ __ ] happened you didn't find
out if you had intercourse I mean I I
know dude I I knocked it out of the
bottle
well you when it doesn't remember there
have been a couple times where I blacked
out and I didn't remember the night
before but it was clear like you wake up
and you're in a Vegas hotel and you
still got a condom on your dick you know
what I mean
you're like you did have sex but you
know just because you don't remember it
feels like it really didn't happen like
it didn't happen like if you don't
remember it it does a town it does it
because it it feels like it never
happened cuz you have no memories of it
I bled I had a blackout drunk when I
worked with Vince Vaughn - one time I
[ __ ] blacked out hard dude we're uh
well we did the support the troops show
I did like five shots of Jager before I
went up and it just so I go so the show
was I was it was just after 9/11 and I
you know Vince Vaughn's like hey come
out and help us raise some money I'm
like okay I'll do that that'd be fun so
I tuned Dewey Beach Delaware and it's at
this like this like country music bar
right and it's a big it's like not a
huge venue but it's a pretty big venue
and it was first-come first-serve right
so the doors open at noon and the shows
until 8:00 it is sold out at around
twelve ten it is packed and they are
drinking all day dude all [ __ ] day
right so I'm like [ __ ] man it's gonna be
crazy so I go up on sell a Meg goes up
and because it's after 9/11 you know
that he's our but it's it's a hard set
you know it's a hard shot dude it's just
like it's I tell you you're walking into
[ __ ] burner at that point there's you
know there's no G got no chance so then
uh then I think I I think they put
Sebastian up and then I went up and is
going well by sucking heckled by this
chick like it like I just getting
heckled
and I threw out some stupid line like
hey why don't you I just leave and go
I'll [ __ ] your cousin some stupid hick
line well she was there with like 80
people and they turned hard dude and to
this day when I hear sha na na na na na
na na hey good bye I still get chills is
that what they started yeah they start
singing that I'm like okay
not today I tried every Comedy Store
thing I had that time so I get off stage
right the whole cast of the wedding
crashers is upstairs right so I just
bombed for the troops and I bombed it
from the [ __ ] wedding crash people
and they were like oh you did great
all I could focus on his own Wilson's
Mouse and how [ __ ] I was so drunk
it was so [ __ ] huge it was so huge
usually a [ __ ] up same way I used to
get one night you got mad at me for
something just that one thing out of
something no I think I went up on stage
at that time one of my favorite people
in the world who still is was my
Armenian drug dealer he would make me
[ __ ] out and I said something when I
brought you up you were drinking yeah I
was my vein roll no that wasn't even
matter you liked that I didn't know you
were drinking until after the situation
went down I said keep her going and
tonight went on stage well I went up
before you was talking by my Armenian
drug dealer you went up there took it
really personal as I was walking out of
the main room you like [ __ ] him I
and then I didn't like stay around to
bait you because I had my own addiction
yeah the last thing I want is to get
into a fistfight with Sam and the cops
come and now he's not drinking and I'm
months Morton what a waste of time I am
I don't remember that I'm super dodo no
I remember approaching I feel awful I
remember no no don't have a few aces
courts here no no no no I member saying
that to you a couple days I prepped what
would you problem DNA it was just a joke
my Armenian drug dealer is real I love
it like my friend then you were like I
didn't like the way you portrayed him to
something
I left you alone but the thing I've
always loved about you that is like so
juvenile but so - a comic like as a
comic
once you become a comedian you get to a
certain level of comedy like eight nine
years you start respecting people
because of their comedy like even if you
don't like yeah if they make you laugh
for sure they make you laugh sure get
the politics and your self-righteousness
right and shove it up your mother's ass
at that time you would always come up to
me you were a young kid and you'd always
come up to me and talk to me about Pablo
Pablo was your world he was your mentor
and that was our connection and I liked
you I naturally liked you but the night
I fell in love with you and you've been
on the Bible on your podcast you buy my
black ass and I just want to reiterate
this to people like at the time I might
say I'm just a young kid you know I
don't know whether I like them or not
like I was a bad boy I just know he's a
regular at the store right so that has
to make me love him as as a comic I have
to love him as a comic he's one of my
brothers at The Comedy Store but he had
a bit as dumb as it sounds about Asians
eating ecstasy and going out and stuff
like that and I'll never forget going
into this is why you have to understand
that there's a point in Tommy where you
have to love the people you're around
that stage if not you're not gonna grow
right but I remember watching you and
we'll say this in public because there's
no big deal this has to be Sam this has
to be 2003 okay yeah thousand four and
you were committing through this bit and
that's a lot and this as crazy as it
sounds that's what I learned about the
word commitment and then years later I
heard Rogan say it and I put it all
together that even if you're bombing
with a joke as long as you believe in
that Jenner I it's the people who go let
me tell you about Kennedy getting shot
in the head and awesome meanwhile it's
not going and they drop it right with
you and I'm looking at you and what you
see was that it was the 7 o'clock show I
hit people my age you know like they
were they on like a 50 and on date night
dude I'm crazy person no no but you're
doing twenty-three-year-old material
right like ecstasy and [ __ ] your eye
and this Chinese guy what was the joke
about the Chinese guy about how our
Asians love axial Asians love ecstasy
yes how smart they are you know my god
their visuals are like [ __ ] Xbox with
[ __ ] Dobby digital sound right the
rest of us is like 8-bit but yeah oh
yeah me being an old guy at the time at
that time I didn't know anything about
ecstasy and I kept watching the same
going on look at this [ __ ] lunatic he
doesn't know that his audience is 20
years older than he is you know you
learn something I asked you last night
before the show after the show at the
ice house I said to you specifically
what did you learn tonight because you
always learned so what hexam when he
walked off the stages I did my a [ __ ]
and they just stand at me but also he
looked at the audience because there's
no lights at the store yeah although you
don't know who you performing it doesn't
worse you look at them and go yeah
they're 55 I don't know anything about
it yeah they know about reefer and Ted
Nugent laughter that wasn't my phone
lovely is a comedian I go because he
didn't give up most comics really just
given up yeah kept pushing the ecstasy
and you were selling the [ __ ] Asian
aspect of it so that's I use that
because you like that joke I use that as
the showcase for the set that showcased
font in the final showcase for mitzi so
I got picked up doing that joke cuz
Duncan pulled me aside he goes I got
your showcase this is how you get him
with mitzi you do one joke about your
ethnic group you do one joke about your
either one your parents and then your
favorite joke so I'm like okay I'm going
to do this bit about my mother being a
power walker
being Armenian going to the beach and
then I'm gonna do a Bayesian ecstasy bed
cuz Joey likes that bit so that's the
bit I'm gonna do the other two I had a
power walkers okay they're not what they
tell me but it's just this whole thing
about I'm a power well no you're a lazy
runner that's what you
right that's what pop you know I
remember that I had this gate about that
and then I had about your mom I bet she
was a power walk then I had a bit about
when I go to the beach and just I'm so
furry man and take a shirt off baby
start crying women in a corner puking
people calling the [ __ ] SPCA right on
me and and I have this whole bit I
didn't know was your clique you had a
little clique right earned Sebastian
Junger my shoe brawny is it yeah [ __ ]
good crowd good crew good crew I love
the Comedy Store I do too I talk to Mars
all the time yeah sure don't gonna fall
for sure it's funny one of my funniest
Eddie stories was I let me tell how much
I love daddy
and he called me one time to give me a
message from Rogen and I looked at the
phone this is how good I am with numbers
for you [ __ ] who thinks I don't
know numbers I remembered his phone
number from visual Wow
one night I dialed it and he answered it
but the thing was I hit my cocaine use
from Rogan he knew about my cocaine use
I just wouldn't do all around him right
but when I'd see Eddie I wouldn't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] with it nobody told Rob
so I would go to a bar called el
compadre where you get the best coke in
town right when I first met heavy and
that's where Eddie would take his dates
Tuesday nights and Wednesday I am
seeking like running away from roses so
fine I don't want Rogan that's all I'm
doing blah but here I am and I would do
a line in the bathroom come out go get a
margarita and who's sitting in the
corner with an arm around the chick that
he Bravo he was all coked up your eye so
Eddie knew it so I kept going back to
the el compadre and I'd bump into Eddie
and I bump into a lot of people but
there was one night in particular this
is like the height of my addiction like
this is 2006 the longest York came out
already right and there was no really
success everybody else was blowing up
with how long as y'all except for me and
I was doing heroin I was doing
everything I'll never forget that I went
down to the el compadre I cop the 40
package from the guitar player and I got
pills
somebody had pills that you do pills
take these and I hate the pills and who
do I bump into but Eddie but this is
like you know I just watch there nothing
happens on the couch I don't care if
you're a fat ugly guy that women do not
talk to you he's like you did wrong you
know chips you stay at the house
nothing's ever gonna happen for you
right like if you go out 300 nights even
if you're fat and ugly you're gonna bump
into a big rock all those nights and
they're gonna suck your dick the odds
are always with you so with me I was an
ugly dude and I didn't have money
Coppola had great things I had to give
the gap and I had cocaine cocaine's of
major closure
oh pretty sure the gift of gab brings
you close to me so now I got you're like
gonna [ __ ] you know saying like wow I
got you but the cocaine I'll just twist
you up and next thing you know was 69 in
and I'm looking at you going oh my god
this chicks at ten and she's eating my
balls like it was just crazy but it was
always at that time I was scared of el
compadre
I lived on the street right I've gone in
a car and I lived in between curse on
and gardener and I'd see all the people
walk out compadre it was crazy but I had
one friend that would go to a compadre
she tell me dummy I could cope there we
got [ __ ] up in there so for years I
didn't know another compadre so I'm
struggling thousand Padre get go meeting
people so bummed when I go in there
after the store I'm [ __ ] late I
already had like a little bit of that
chewy coke yes it wasn't good
yeah what is that when it speaks like
that yeah this is like should we go quit
was good enough it didn't take you over
the cocaine Mountain talk to people and
talk about your career with all this
[ __ ] that's got thinner or some [ __ ]
yeah so I would do the chewy coconut the
chewy coke didn't have it I'd make the
investment and then have somebody drive
me over the compadre I was home anyway I
was sleeping in some
his apartment in that block anyway
whether it was Ralphie may Celine Shawn
Ralph Doug Stanhope I would find
somebody to sleep even though I was
homeless so by this time I got a place
and I going there one night and I'm
buying my little late-night package and
who's in there but he problem and again
nothing happens when you stay on the
couch I'm [ __ ] stuck on the thing and
there's a hot chick by herself and like
anything in this table knows especially
Lea how [ __ ] for anybody we were at we
were at more in steakhouse one day on
coke - no no no no no no no recently
this had to be two years ago that's my
wife is having only let's go to Morton
sake house some woman passed by me
excuse me lady you're looking [ __ ]
tremendous tonight she's like oh my god
when she came back she gave me a number
she had to be 80 years old my point my
point being that you know a gift again
right cocaine so right now compadre who
do I bump into but Eddie at the same
time when I'm bumping daddy I'm talking
to this chick
this has to be let's pretend it was 15
years ago maybe right so I'm 40 years
old I'm broke I'm living on Gavin's
floor God knows where the [ __ ] I'm
living I go to compadre I get a $50 rock
which in those days was tremendously
helpful I can exit whoo chunking ah and
I'd crush it up I'd do little blasts and
I'm not there to remiss but this girl
comes out you know just move to Hawaii
she does not know about our way and she
starts talking about tequila you know I
love tequila and then I thought that's
Aquila and tequila and tequila to get
home and about to keel I know Corvo and
sober got a little dry she does have you
ever eaten a worm and in all this
species was one time I hate a worm like
I sucked the guy's dick for an hour and
I'm like really you know somebody tells
a hyper information worms you know with
somebody tells you that type of
information when you just meet them
that's just fine or really issue does as
a matter of fact whatever I drink
tequila I got a sudden urge I love to
suck dick she didn't say it in that way
she
the common way to say Falah do fellatio
what's what do you know what's fellatio
is when you eat [ __ ] now fleshes when
when you look to the ixuy
she was smart knob she was very white
and she's telling me all this [ __ ] and I
have no money like I have like $8 and
she's telling me now she'd read I
remember going to the bar thing they
don't listen Joey whatever it was Joey I
know Joey keys but like $20 and tabs and
send us over for shots of tequila knows
you got it and I gave like I was like
salud and there was 20 people in the
patio and them elects hello and I'm
eating pills I think I got a surge your
love oh I'm doing that guitar player
coke which is cartel cocaine the cocaine
there was brilliant that's what is he
little hand all that mariachi music is
all about drug deal yeah that's what
Lindsey Lohan was getting her blow
that's a good [ __ ] long been there
[ __ ] getting blasted
I don't know humbling at home I don't
know what happens I'm talking to this
chick and I'm the coke I said some talk
about sucking my dick and that's you
know i black out and we're in men coming
into the el compadre bathroom pissing
and she's giving me a [ __ ] from the
bathroom and again we walk out and in
those days when she sucked my dick the
conversations over there's no more
cocktails there's no more cocaine hold
on I got a call hold on a friend of mine
just let me go get my friend bail that's
it
I wake up the next day I take a shower
I'm all over the tequila I take my
aspirins and I'm trying to think about
what happened the night before like it's
that deep of a black eye my mom I have
an allergy to alcohol yeah for sure a
certain amount of a ball I [ __ ] pass
out so I'll never forget that the phone
rings on my pager goes off and it's
Eddie like aw anything goes well hey man
I'm just worried about you what happened
to you last night I know what happened
to you you know one minute we're talking
next minute you gotta go you were
talking to some hot chick I go oh [ __ ]
that's right that's right I was talking
that hot chick he goes what happened
with that I know you know what bro
that's when you know you [ __ ] blacked
out it at the light while I was on the
phone with Eddie it came to me that the
chickens suck my dick Eddie do you know
that chick suck my dick last night he
goes where you took the home but no I
got no home right there and el compadre
goes where I go in the bathroom he goes
right out in the open I go no in the
stall and then he asked me a thousand
dollar question he goes did you close
the store I go why would I close the
store yeah she's like my dick yeah if I
was sucking hug dick I closed the store
cuz I'm conscientious that's how crazy
el compadre in those days like that was
the craziest Hollywood stories I have
know you have a great story about Dublin
diary tell this no no but let me ask you
this dumb before I go any rather than
did we do that thing together where the
people were [ __ ] outside and we had
to do stand-up comedy it was that Jason
Tebow Duncan that must have been
somebody else that know I've done shows
where people are [ __ ] we did the show
up in the hills of the game is 1500 flat
and it was the people from what was the
guy that was showing woman her tits you
went to a bar girls come on Wow No
so it was like these Armenian [ __ ] I
have guys that came through the store
and they picked up like five or six
comics the other day we're trying to put
together
Jason Tebow wasn't one of the headliners
they gave you a bag of joints they put
you in a trailer and then people are
gonna [ __ ] around the pool and you were
gonna go up on stage and do jokes any
disgusting Eddie disgusting kids number
people you want to actually watch from
yeah right it was disgusting right I
still remember this one husband came
yoked up on steroids looking at Mad Dog
and everybody's like my wife is here and
his wife was maybe like a sex you know
I'm saying she was a filthy [ __ ]
animal like when she took her SH and was
oh [ __ ] free dirt on her feet ah horse
never forget that she got on top of the
diving board when people were just
[ __ ] her and he would just stand
there like look how good a pichia ask my
wife is like it was just totally
disgusting and we got there at 1:00 in
the afternoon and we had to sit through
this like I'm a big guys I'm a pig when
I tell you that I was
like disgusted there was a pool people
were [ __ ] by the pool then they had
where you change you put your towel and
gently the pool thing I wanted there at
one point and there was people [ __ ]
everywhere and people were taping this
and then we'll we had to wait for it to
get dark for the Communists start ah so
we got there at 1:00 with the shooting
porn
what were they what they were gonna
shoot was five comedians wit sex around
you and they were gonna sell it this is
way before the internet guys this is it
had to be 2001-2002 somebody found good
online the guys lost their ass oh yeah
girls gone wild no no no these were guys
that were like girls gone wild they had
an idea and their big plan was on crazy
yeah what that big plan was they were
gonna rent TV on Thanksgiving night and
just push the ad all night I want it now
and you'll see comedians and girls
having sex and ba ba ba ba ba bro they
invested so much money
Wow like they told us what they invested
part of the deal for me was like 1500
and like a bag of joints they let you
jump in no you didn't want to jump in
trust me there was and then they hired
like it's like nudists nudists are never
buddy you want so naked it's almost like
a warning though it's a warning they
hired female models that were extras
good-looking ones and they didn't know
where they were going to so because they
thought they were going to a mall they
got there to see all these ugly women
getting [ __ ] by different men and
gangbanging and [ __ ] and some of them
started leaving angry and crying and
[ __ ] like that that was just disgusting
and I still remember being on stage and
getting heckled and become their girl go
[ __ ] yourself you wouldn't be here and
then she got really pissed and every
time I walk past is you give me the
finger the rest on I [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] loser and finally I default like
a [ __ ] is some [ __ ] you you or you
would be a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you weren't
area I look like going back onstage
they're just going off on it you weren't
I know I think it was me Duncan Trussell
who's a sweet harder than no one the
best one of the best they hire like five
of the wrong [ __ ] comics for that
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude that that thing was
doomed even before they decide comics do
you feel so you know like I bumped into
him like three or four months later at
the store they came up to like looking
for like five hundred back like their
dads down and then I you're not gonna
believe what happen we advertise we only
sold one hundred and thirty six units we
took a bath we gotta pay our family back
now the money we borrow them it was
embarrassing so it's a crazy idea dude I
mean that's a sometimes people just
because they have money I've learned
this just cuz you have mine doesn't mean
you're smart you know what I'm saying
like there's some people got cash
they just make horrible horrible
business decisions well I'll hear
especially I've seen that that what is
that investment when you're not
guaranteed the investment package called
something there's people that just do
that it's got a high return but by it's
like but if you lose the money you lose
it like yeah give it away so people will
give away a half a million in five
hundred thousands in fifty thousands
don't invest a half a million and a
fifty thousand with the hope that one of
those fifty thousand I'll give my I
yield interest and cover their losses
and they can make extra money there's
something that it's called
I don't have a run in economists anymore
it's back in the day I've done shows
where people are having sex we used to
do naughty shows in our swingers clubs
and we went to the world-famous green
door in Las Vegas
oh yeah so we were supposed to do
another casino in a to freaked out
they're like no we don't want porn stars
it was it's just a weird it was a weird
time in Vegas right so I had this huge
show put together I had a guy from CSI
wanted to do the show he wanted to do
some funny stupid skit about like DNA on
the girl stuff because we had porn stars
and they'll be like find out who was a
murderer through the DNA but uh so I
call around and I remember my buddy had
did a show head to the show at the green
door and I'm like what they want to do
comedy called the guy boom done we sell
like 300 tickets in like honestly a half
an hour that's how quickly the show so
that because it was part of ABM weekend
and all that [ __ ]
so we go there and uh so this guy the
swingers man like here's I've learn
about super rich people they're all
[ __ ] they all bang each other's
girlfriends it's just like they just get
bored they all just [ __ ] each other
right so at this swinger this guy ran
the swing club knew all the all the
ballers in Vegas and he got us the
fattest suite I've ever spent house I've
ever seen in my life for you for forgot
me
Jason Tebow and I think I won one of the
big porn stars that you know she was
gonna stay with us - what was it
what's the girl you're friends with that
I like Tara Patrick or Patrick I loved
she did one of the most beautiful people
you've ever seen your life so we go to
this hotel it's at the Paris it's up and
we get our keys are like wow that's
really high so we go up and it's the
last floor man we're like holy [ __ ] and
we walked down we're like where is it
did we get double doors man open and
double doors it's like half the top
floor of like the Paris it was the
biggest hotel room I've ever stayed in
my life and it was ours for the whole
weekend for doing this show at the green
door we go to the green door we do the
show it's a huge smash afterwards and
while I'm doing stand-up
people are just [ __ ] all over the
place and I've learned from strip clubs
that basically what swingers clubs are
are just where are black guys with
dreads go to bang polar bears that's
what happened just bigs a polar bear a
big fat white chick a polar guy that's
just you see these guys and dreads just
[ __ ] crushing these very large well
these swingers clubs does I'm not hip to
this [ __ ] what was the famous one in New
York I was taking taken that's the word
I'm sorry I was taking one night and one
of my drunk cocaine stupors I met
somebody out and they said let's go to
that club and I walked in with him I
think I lasted eight minutes because my
Catholic whatever just got in the way
like there was just people [ __ ] I
didn't I didn't like the concept of
I walked in here with my girlfriend on
my wife that's the concept I didn't like
I don't mind if you've got a coupon on
the side there's some 20 year old
[ __ ] check that do you want her but
like the people next to me it was their
wives and the two guys like you like
such a great dick [ __ ] telling dudes
are into that it's that's the point I'm
not that confident about so I didn't
like that [ __ ] then once I was taken to
a 10:40 club and that was a horrible
experience as a child like 16 where was
$10 it was $9.99 to get your dick sucked
what but it was $10 and for it's like
Groupon prices yeah it was ten thousand
forty cents plus tax
so his ninth anything that you had to
pay tax on a [ __ ] so it was 1040 so
you paid the ten thousand forty cents
they gave you a ticket stub and you
walked in the back and it was like a
hundred guys have it and then what they
did was they set up a bar they had
different bars in there so you just
drinking that way drinking like me and
Daddy and then like a red light would go
off and the door would open up and they
push a bunch of girls like like young
hookers loving countries and you had a
[ __ ] grab and then to go back into
the area you had to give the ticket to
the guy and they would take you into the
back and it was basically cubicles just
cubicles with a sink like a prison
bathroom and you opened the curtain and
you went in there and she pulled out a
bucket and she put hot water in the
bucket and she had a sponge
then she took your dick out cuz she
washed your dick and she washed your
balls this is the only city to [ __ ]
the city had don't sleep with New York
City huh this is 19 this was 1981 like I
went there for a birthday party it was
Pablo Pedro I forget he's dead now God
rest his soul
I knew him with his brother they had a
football the family had a candy company
so at night he would take they had
trucks that delivers like Hershey bars
and Milky Way's that's what the family
obregón then his name was Pedro or
Breanna and he loves oka houses so we
were drinking one night and they said
let's go into the city and I got the
collar with them and I wanted at 10:40
club but I was Catholic
my mother just died yeah I didn't know
about this [ __ ] night this place is fun
let's go in there and that was it $10
and I said $10 [ __ ] let me tell you
something it was one of the worst
experiences of my life
yes you grabbed it like the chick I
grabbed I didn't even know like I was
there for a half hour just drinking cuz
it was like dollar drinks but the room
would smell like cologne like you know
all those guys that they tell you how
much they get laid
it was those guys no yeah it was all
those type of guys like the prom when I
go out women I gotta beat him off me
you're lyin they were all in there with
their Colonna and talking like they were
businessmen and you got to grab these
chicks it was at them and crying all
night of course is a [ __ ] horror show
and then they'd look but they upgrade
you in the back so are they washing your
balls and stuff no condom they suck your
dick it was 1970 1979 1980 81 no condoms
they blow you and then they'd upgrade
you so for an extra 10 bucks
it wasn't around the world I'll never
forget that telling me and around the
world and I'm like what's around the
world she's like that's when I suck your
dick and I lick your balls and you [ __ ]
and I was like all right let's do the
around the world and then she took her
stockings off and a shirt and it was
just I was horrified I was 17 you know I
really they're just [ __ ] beat nob it
had just been beaten up like she turned
around and a [ __ ] lips were hanging all
that like I wanted love like I was
looking to be loved Eddie is that
nothing more wrong than you were looking
for a pretty woman for yeah it was $10
but then she put the I don't know she
put the condom on me she got on top of
me first and it was like a metal bed
like a detention bed and you could hear
20 people [ __ ] at once oh it was all
around he was this is wide open
and I'll never forget her rubbing
against me and me close the minds
knowing how many diseases am I gonna get
in the middle of all that she stopped
and she was you know from an extra five
you could eat my [ __ ] and I just [ __ ]
uh what's when they have you in a month
I hit bumped yeah and she flew off bro
and I put my [ __ ] chair and I walked
out of a I walked the 42nd Street took
the bus home that was like one of the
lowest levels of my life oh for sure I
got a low level story like it was really
the old this is the only time I ever had
sex with the girl and didn't want to
finish just pulled up my pants and got
the [ __ ] out let me tell you the story
this is I was single between 2000 and
2010 I went ten years I strategically
stayed away from relationships I started
you know doing seminars teaching
jiu-jitsu and before I had two thousand
two thousand ten two thousand two
thousand ten how a single-user a bunch
of good ideas I would just having fun
man
Dayton just getting crazy and that's
when a ten planet was born and before I
had any affiliates there was this one
school in Tennessee one school that
would have me out every other month they
would have me out and I didn't have any
affiliates I just had one squash team I
didn't even have a school I was you know
the beginning of 10th planet was me
teaching out of some dirty-ass boxing
gym in West Hollywood across street from
that old Trader Joe's bomb squad bomb
squad was I kept Keenen Ivory Wayans
there exactly he went he went there he
was old school I knew Sam before I got
Scott into that's how I got sky and
titles both you guys before temple yeah
yeah really yeah ten planner
I knew you guys 2001 2002 and 2003 was
the beginning of 10th planet but anyways
right there 2003 2004 I'm going to this
city and this I'd never been to a city
like that before in my life I just
started traveling and it's one of those
cities where you you fly into Atlanta
and then Atlanta you take a little prop
plane to this one small little town in
Tennessee this guy's flying me out for
Bristol Tennessee
tri-cities so I went there a lot and
when I'd go that stay the whole weekend
I would just show I was tripped out that
anybody would even fly me out for a
seminar right and the guy that was
flying me out his name was Dee Smith and
he was like the coolest [ __ ] guy ever
he just had me out every other week and
you know he was really in the rubber
garden and all that the twister and all
that [ __ ] so um and when when I'd go out
there was one club in this small little
town one club on a Saturday night called
state line and it had the college kids
thirty people in their thirties and
forties in their fifties and sixties
everybody was in this goddamn club that
one [ __ ] Club and um and you
know I was out there looking you know
for female companionship you know what
I'm saying
like I'm like this is my last night I
leave tomorrow you know and we went out
to this club that club state line I mean
you can't even call it a club is like a
bar but I mean there wasn't really any
success going on there and this way I
forget his name but this one guy said
hey man we can go to Johnson City
there's a bigger club so Johnson City
was like a step up from the small little
town that like 15,000 people population
small little town them in the boonies of
Tennessee so I thought [ __ ] it you know
I don't got nothing else to do he goes
do it I'll Drive you will go to Johnson
City there's just badass Club I'm like
let's go so we drove about an hour to
Johnson City and we get in town it's a
horrible club I mean it is a step above
the right the bar was just had but it
was horrible and he said I know this
girl up on stage and there's just girl
she looked like she was she was drunk as
[ __ ] she looked like Huckleberry Finn
great nice you know she just [ __ ] up
teeth and just she was skinny and she
had her pants unzipped and she was
dancing on this stage it wasn't a strip
club but you she thought it was and
everybody's like dancing dirty on her
and goes you can [ __ ] her if you
am i how do you know it goes dude I
could [ __ ] her anytime I want my Holly
and and this dude didn't have any teeth
either no kidding
nice guy but I was like [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and I and I said no thank you
dad let's get the [ __ ] out of here you
know it's bad when the story's not over
yet I was like I thought about it I was
on the fence man I was a little wrong
and I'm like we're in Tennessee you know
to me kind of drop your standards when
you know like [ __ ] now I just looked at
her up on stage and dudes rolling all
over her dancing dirty and she literally
had her their pants zipped down trying
to be sexy buttoned open and dancing on
the stage and I said [ __ ] it let's just
get the [ __ ] out and cuz you sure man
you sure you can get that one yeah hmm
I'm sure let's get the [ __ ] out all
right so we go to the parking lot we get
in the car and we're trying to get out
of this parking lot and here she comes
as we're driving up Jesus like stalled
is she she's got to be like no no no
early 20s when she stumbling out of the
club she perfect timing goes last chance
you sure we take her to my house right
now
am i [ __ ] I said all right [ __ ] it let's
get let's just do it so he grabbed her
throws her in the car we go back to his
house like his mom's then we go in the
basement he's got a big screen in the
basement and it's us just us three
watching TV just for a second I'm like
you know what and he gets up and he
walks away and gives me a little wink
let's go for it I'm like and she's just
like sitting there just not even talking
and I thought okay so we started making
out a little bit and his [ __ ] gross
dude I pulled down her pants and put on
a condom I'm like there's no way I'm
[ __ ] this chick without a condom
put on a condom I put it in and she's
just looking like she's dead yeah I got
this dead look on yeah and I took a
couple pumps and I just looked at or not
and I thought [ __ ] this [ __ ] it's so not
worth it oh yeah I was afraid to come I
pulled out [ __ ] snap that rubber off
the road threw it against the [ __ ]
floor and I went upstairs and told the
guy let's get the [ __ ]
out of here because what happened did
you [ __ ] I'm like not really dude let's
just get the [ __ ] out of here so he
drove me back and and that was the only
that was the only time I ever stopped in
the middle of sex and just I was afraid
to have an orgasm I just wanted to get
though wow your baggage had your kids
[ __ ] oh you better let me go take a piss
real quick well back you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here now do you
think that though she be thinking we're
back here just a little cross but you
know just go listen tell about
podcasting is every every [ __ ] episode
is something different I couldn't stick
to the same [ __ ] episode every episode
so we try to switch it up in time to
time we got great guest this week don't
worry about that we're always here
changing [ __ ] lives you understand me
don't forget this Friday and Saturday
I'm in Philly and DC they're sold out
but if you don't feel anger your way in
there get in there
and then there's tickets still available
for Fox Fox woods on the 29th or the
28th 29th of September the still tickets
will be either sold out where's Bob I'll
be down there is [ __ ] so get your [ __ ]
together [ __ ] this is my only
Florida appearance so Tampa Miami for a
lot of they'll get your roller skates
and if that cocaine ready you can run up
with 95 on [ __ ] roller skates with a
cape on that's so crazy how your whole
dream started down there on that in that
little boxing gym like your vision you
know saying I had no idea I would be
able to get other people to want to be
part of the 10th planet Association I
had no clue I I was just happy that I
had a you know group of 3040 guys yeah I
mean you have to have more affiliates it
just it wasn't even a thought I remember
George or Joe back then back when he was
fighting the UFC and then you hear he
had 12 schools I thought what the [ __ ]
is he a multi-millionaire or what he had
12 [ __ ] schools I couldn't believe it
I never thought I'd even have two and
then you know a couple people asked you
know how do we get affiliate
with you and I thought why would you
want to get affiliated with me I'm just
some [ __ ] Mexican he's a who yet all
these legendary Brazilians all around
why would you want to learn you gets it
from the Mexico I thought you went to
[ __ ] I bet you want to take a look of
all on Benjamin and everyone the Owen
Benjamin [ __ ] twisted [ __ ] no how old
were you when you got into conspiracy
theories and what my whole life I've
always what was the first conspiracy
that you are you're the mark I'm on the
market it was the first conspiracy that
you thought about how old are you I
remember when the Iron Sheik and Hacksaw
Jim Duggan got bus in the car together
and I was like hey dude these
[ __ ] aren't supposed to like
each other and boom I'm like oh that's
it's all [ __ ] and that kind of my
dad's always made always raised me to be
a paranoid person you know he said don't
believe anything you see and half what
you don't believe anything you hear and
half what you see your dad's an
immigrant my dad no he's uh no he's like
second generation okay so he was raised
here yeah but he's old Italian and he's
like you know he's just like he'd be
like you know if someone disrespects you
yes courts your earth with them just you
know just wonderful advice they gave me
all the time and it was just like so I
always questioned everything always
always never believe what was the first
time you got into conspiracies a brother
when I found out everybody wasn't
Catholic it's okay it happens yeah I
thought everybody was Catholic you know
I grew up in a neighborhood were
everybody was Catholic we had a
neighborhood church Our Lady of pill are
right there on sixth Street in Santa Ana
Oh
you know when you watch TV all the
Catholic holidays coincided with what
you saw on Diff'rent Strokes you know
they would have Christmas specials and
easter specials and Halloween specials I
thought everybody was Catholic but then
once I think I was 11
well once I found out that there's a
whole shitload of Jews and Muslims and
and Hindus I thought wait a minute who's
right here how come they're saying that
if you don't believe their [ __ ] you're
going to hell and they're saying if you
don't believe their [ __ ] you're going to
hell but we're saying that too and then
at that point I thought Oh
okay everybody's full of [ __ ] so I just
became an atheist right that I didn't
believe in anything I thought these
[ __ ] also anything that
anything to do with religion from the
time I was 11 12 13 I was like you guys
are just full of [ __ ]
because how do you how could you know
there's more I think there's you know
isn't there more Muslims than Christians
yeah and isn't isn't I don't know
something like that right or even if
it's like even that's still a lot of
people that don't believe in Christ so
that was really when I started doubting
what the mainstream was given me and
then in 1985 when I was 15 on 20/20 they
did a special report on heavy metal
music and it was it was based on the
PMRC and they were talking about you
know if your kids are listening to
Twisted Sister or do
they're probably Satanist and I was
balls deep in the Slayer and I thought
what are you talking about the listed
sister I'm 15 like these [ __ ]
supposed to know everything you you're
holding up the wrong albums Judas Priest
Judas Priest saying satanic you need to
hold up creator and destruction and
Sodom like I was into them like bands
that were straight up talking about
Satanism cuz like yeah do what you know
or like you'd listen to a Motley Crue
maybe there's some bass port backward
masking [ __ ] on Led Zeppelin or
something like that but Slayer was
riding straight out there was no
subliminal messages there wasn't any
backward messages that were telling you
that we're gonna you know every song was
about killing babies and and demons
rising from hell and sacrificing priests
and and [ __ ] corpses and sending
their souls to hell you know and all of
a sudden watching 20/20 and they're
talking to my [ __ ] motley crew and
Judas Priest being satanic the kids like
those [ __ ] are satanic 180 fine
I mean so these kids will listen to
music backwards remember that they got
taken to court Judas Priest because yeah
so took it killed themselves as a kid
who is balls deep and amazing guys are
going after the wrong bag you're not
going why aren't you going after King
Diamond here's his
album covers straight yeah panic he's
telling you he's satanic but they were
ignoring all the bands that were balls
deep into Satan then they were going
after bands that had nothing to do with
sing so what do you think I do what
Satan what do you think then why were
they so I thought okay so I can't trust
none of this [ __ ] these guys have it all
wrong and that just got the ball rolling
and then the firt and then I was in
speed metal bands in my teens playing
drums and you know I was in a bag called
resistance and we were conspiracy
theorists but we didn't know [ __ ] there
was no internet all I knew is I couldn't
trust anybody and we were writing songs
about you know anti-government songs and
nuclear war songs and the typical [ __ ]
that hardcore metal bands were writing
about you it was all anti-establishment
but we didn't know what the [ __ ] we were
talking about but we just knew we
couldn't trust anybody we just knew that
I gotta actually both the question real
point yeah I always you know looking
back at it even when I was living it I
thought even when my mind was in a dark
place and I would listen to Black
Sabbath I knew that it was for some
reason I knew was a marketing something
about it
yeah there is no because I would hear
them singing but Heisey would wear a
cross so Black Sabbath they were they
were a band that you can you can go
after them 20:21 after Black Sabbath
they did they didn't have some crosses
and they were never uh they were master
reality because there were satanic light
right but they were nothing compared to
diss the German thrash metal scene Sodom
and destruction and Kreator and Slayer
and all that [ __ ]
Bathory King Diamond they were every
song was about Satan and worshipping
Satan you know so to go after deal and
and Judas Priest's and Motley Crue and
that [ __ ] that that made me really lose
any kind of [ __ ] faith do you think
they went after those bands because they
had investments in those bands is that
what is that why they went out I don't
know what the real motives were
now now looking back my maybe they were
pushing it you know I mean maybe they
were provide by pretending that they
were against it they were really pushing
it and we're trying to corrupt the youth
I mean if you take a look at like
something like the Grateful Dead
the CIA's fingerprints are all over that
man yeah they were the house band yeah
for the guys who made all the acid for
the CIA and we're basically we're the
Grateful Dead went and played that's
where ass would spread yeah maybe they
would let Slayer get away with anything
they wanted right lair had a song called
it's one of their biggest songs ever
called Angel of Death and it's all about
killing Jews and ovens you know I mean
that the opening line is aa switch the
meaning of pain the way that I want you
to die slow death immense decay
something that cleansed off of your life
for whatever but no one ever touched
there they never touched them no one
ever bothered them and a song after that
was a [ __ ] song about frying Jews and
no one said [ __ ] Angel of Death no one
said anything they just let it go you
know it's always that I wanted they
wanted it to get them it was 87 I was on
the run from the cops looking for me in
Aspen and I went to Boulder and they
worked out a job on a car wash like
Rambo would if the cops are looking for
him and all the kids I worked at all had
long hair and at this time I was I was
just I was into cocaine right I wasn't
into bands anyone and read the Capri
more Rolling Stone but they were talking
about Slayer this is the [ __ ] you know
and I'm deep into Sabbath stone and I
remember listening to it going no this
is not gonna work in my [ __ ] world at
all this spooky [ __ ] and I just didn't
even know but it was satanic until yeah
you just said no super fast and it was
the chunk of my life right the light
black oh my god I dove in [ __ ] head
first my first my first introduction of
speed meadow was a band from
Canada called exciter and at that point
I was thirteen fourteen and I would buy
I wanted to buy I was going after banned
the most obscure bands I wanted to
discover bands right and I and I I
wanted to get a band that no an album
that no one else had that was amazing
that had an amazing cover and had to
have a [ __ ] satanic sick ass cover so
I'm I'm out looking to discover bands
and and I read in Circus magazine a
little tiny review on exciter the album
heavy metal mania and it was a great
review and they said super ultra heavy
and I thought wow that's it just just
the the album cover blew me away the
review enticed me so I went out and
bought the record I didn't find how the
heavy metal maniac but they had another
album called violence and force and
album cover was awesome so I bought that
I went oh it drove them music plus on my
bike bought the album got home listen to
it me [ __ ] hate it was Speedman I
never heard speed metal before it was
super fast was like punk it was weird
just it was horrible I thought [ __ ] what
I'm gonna take this album back first
thing in the morning but take it back if
I didn't like a now am I take it back
get my money back right I was too poor
that was $6.99
oh so the next morning I plan on I might
take this [ __ ] garbage back but the
next day I thought okay let me give it
one more chance so I listen to it again
and for some reason it just got it and I
just fell in love with it and then from
that point on I got into Slayer and just
you know metallic then it got deeper and
deeper into the German thrash metal
scene it that only lasted really then I
started playing I'm making music like
that started playing drums in speed
metal bands like that writing satanic
lyrics and a nuclear war lyrics and all
that [ __ ] I did that but by the time I
was eighteen and nineteen I got burnt
out on it and then I started slowly
getting into hip-hop and more Nine Inch
Nails vibe and then I got sick of speed
metal and just left the whole thing and
just started doing move to Hollywood
left the speed metal
and formed a band called blackened kill
Symphony that was dark heavy lattice but
with a lot of synth like land snails in
the Cure in Depeche Mode but what had
hip hop and feel and I had a rapper my
my best friend you know we moved to
Hollywood togethers names James Watson
he was the rapper he was the guitar
player in my speed metal band black guy
who played guitar in resistance named
James Watson is my best friend we moved
to Hollywood said [ __ ] speedin and I
said [ __ ] drums so I killed the drums
started playing guitar and we formed
black and kill symphony right when we
got to Hollywood and he started playing
now he became the rapper and then he
would play guitar every now and then but
I'm a weird [ __ ] dude and when Slayer
came out I never got into it but I was
always into like Metallica that whole I
love those clothes
Slayers harder harder harder harder and
was way faster yeah wait that ac/dc I
love that Metallica were up on Motown
though that was my [ __ ] let me ask you a
question because today I Roberto
Clemente they would have been 83 years
Wow greatest athletes of all time just
did more for anybody what the [ __ ] was
the Bermuda Triangle I don't want to
hear my [ __ ] Slayer guys [ __ ]
Metallica I want no conspiracy theories
what the [ __ ] was the [ __ ] I never
really got into it could be a vortex
dude I think they solved it but yeah
it's just like it's a vortex probably uh
it's just got weird energy and [ __ ] just
happens when you go into but it's also
like got a [ __ ] conspiracy theories
are you they even get into [ __ ] the
Bermuda Triangle even me I'm not a
conspiracy guy and I even had to do some
search well tell me about it I mean like
I just feel like it was just as bad luck
place yeah that's a just bunch of bad
luck and diamond there and that's what
Roberto Clemente's plane went down they
recovered some parts of the plane but
they never recovered the body there was
just so many things that would go on
when I was growing up in the you know
yeah that was a big thing it's almost
like John mulaney's bit about how you
know when you
as a kid he thought quick Sam be a much
bigger problem in his life you know now
like you never see quickly quickly
well yeah quick sale in the jungle I was
a kid there was everywhere yeah you're
like you quicksand in quicksand aha
right you say three black guys like we
can't go cuz they got quicksand yeah I
just never understood a lot of quicksand
the Bermuda Triangle you always thought
man we can't fly through that one my
favorite theorist I got into cuz I gave
up after a while was Kennedy was what
generally yeah why'd you give up on it
because it doesn't take a genius to know
our government had something to do with
it Oh perfect yeah so once that's like
my government already decided that it
was a conspiracy and no one talks about
it so it's not even that they shouldn't
even be a debate anymore in 1977 the
House Committee on assassinations they
reviewed after after like you know uh 14
years or whatever they opened they
reopened up the investigation on his
murder and they decided yet the
government decided yes and I think that
me said yes there was a conspiracy it
was more than just one person there were
other people involved and then that's it
then they just put a halt to it they
said yes there was other people involved
because really it was the the debate is
was was Lee Harvey Oswald alone nut
assassin or were there more people
involved that's all it was she was just
was there a bunch of people or was it
one person our own government already
came to the cryogen right the fact that
it's a debate it's crazy because it
shouldn't be a debate there are people
that think one bullet didn't believe our
own government already decided that it
was me a people and then Trump
Declassified all this crazy [ __ ] that
basically put George Bush there in
Dallas that day which is kind of
interesting
yeah and maybe look at George Bush like
he's such a gangster [ __ ] dude
his family is very close with the
Hinckley's right because they're all old
oil money out of Texas
so the Hinkley's the bush is a friend
who takes a shot at rent kenny at reagan
boom Hinckley what we got what would
happened if Reagan what it died George
or jingler becomes president that guy he
was Ruth he was the former
head of the CIA who became vice
president and his dad Prescott Bush
helped form the CIA his dad a super
powerful Prescott Bush he was involved
in funding the Nazis through Union Bank
Prescott Bush George singers dad and
she's dad Samuel Bush was the right-hand
man of Frank Rockefeller and they the
bushes and the Rockefellers are their
balls-deep that's like super CFR just
Illuminati type [ __ ] the running [ __ ]
the bushes are you kidding oh yeah those
are the dude of the battery years of
human history the bushes and somewhat
the Clintons basically wiped out the
Kennedy family dynasty remember they
were like the top political family like
in the country yeah not even close
anymore wiped them out now it's bushes
and the Clintons
so while so while George senior was the
vice president under Reagan no Reagan we
went through the iran-contra scandal
right and that was about running drugs
and guns to support the Sandinistas and
like you know all that [ __ ] Marin
miserably
yeah and Central America all that [ __ ]
and what was going on was that the CIA
was bringing in coke the Mena Arkansas
they were dropping it off that was the
drop-off point Mena Arkansas who in the
in the 80s Bill Clinton is the governor
of Arkansas who had who had to allow
this [ __ ]
so while Bill Clinton was the governor
of Arkansas that's when all the coke was
coming in through Arkansas and Bill was
like he was allowing it and this and
then he becomes the president after
George senior right so George senior is
basically Bill Clinton's boss during the
whole iran-contra thing and then
coincidentally Bill Clinton be it
becomes the next president yeah they
hooked him up because he hooked them up
yeah so when they're when you see George
senior and Bill Clinton
on stage debating like in the
presidential debates like talking about
sending jobs overseas and raising taxes
or cutting taxes and all that [ __ ]
they're really partners and grab their
do for sure they're like you got this
they tagged him off in ours
it's crazy as gangster [ __ ] going on oh
my god forget the day I first spoke to
you about Mena Arkansas we had that talk
well here's the thing that pisses me off
about this now if you watched narcos if
you watch netflix they have six or seven
shows describing to you the explosion of
cocaine of the mid 70s to the mid
eighties and you look at something like
that you know Lee doesn't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about Sam trip isn't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
here this Eddie in a way because I saw
with you guys are reading I saw cocaine
was very recreational it wasn't around
it was acid and reefer and all of a
sudden it just by 81 it just took off
now at this time if you read The
Chronicles in the [ __ ] the government
finds out about cocaine right but what
the government really found out was was
about the money that they were making
with cocaine and at the end of the day
we don't care if you're doing coke and
selling but what nothing comes over here
for the mouse nothing comes here for the
mouse I remember being a cocaine addict
in 81 82 83 you could buy cocaine for a
hundred gram to 80 to 250 an Eightball
an 85 that all changed once the
government got involved in the month I'm
living through this yeah I'm living
through this and I'm hearing constant
awesome don't from from 76 to 82 if he
did a line of cocaine guys it was like
tasting cake for the first time the good
[ __ ] right you went
and it would go down in the back your
throat would get numb and it tastes kind
of pinky and your nose would get kind of
numb and you didn't get high you didn't
get that you got high that your eyes
kind of got red and they would play
tricks on you and after like 2 or 3 or 4
lines that's when you would get this
elevation of high well that I changed
over the years you know they told me
that they'd said that how that they
really got to the cartel was the problem
that we had created was that just to
make cocaine the final wash to make it
taste good is ether alcohol is a maze
cocaine paste that's why if I smell
anything with ether it illuminates me
that's cocaine it's cocaine yeah ether
alcohol let's go ok ha ha ha so there
was a time where the roughest thing
wasn't getting cocaine out of Colombia
it was getting ether into Colombia the
product to wash that's what it's called
to wash the final bride once they
couldn't get the ether in they started
using [ __ ] gasoline and turpentine
and you could taste it in the coke oh
yeah that coke became cracked people
started saying we can't sell it like I
remember snorting coke that smelled like
cat piss oh my and then you would have
headaches for three days the coke was
astonishing it was like 99% pure you
would put it down on your tongue in your
head would be [ __ ] numb point oh you
couldn't even talk making business ideas
but it would burn the bottom of your
nose like and that became crack people
sort of taking that cope and gonna [ __ ]
it which I'm not gonna sell it just burn
it down into this lowest thing you know
they made crack in those days it was
horrible like Iran I knew these guys in
the early 80s that were already making
because there was it was freebase at
first right and free basis for the rich
and famous to freebase cocaine oh my god
to snort cocaine was one thing but to
freebase it
that was Belushi that was Robin will you
have [ __ ] money
[ __ ] you money because bro a little rock
just shrinks on you you gotta have a
good a guy there cooking it with a silk
[ __ ] scarf or socks that are made
from silk so for every gram you use you
only get eight tenths back meaning you
could smoke eight tenths in two minutes
so I saw this evolution and even though
I was part of it and even though I
thought it was cool and even though I
had three I grew up with it
now looking back it ruined the country
oh for sure destroy the country for our
own government destroy the country I
mean and this doesn't just go to cocaine
you know if you walked around New York
City in 1967 and 68 and 69 and 70 I will
tell you that if you saw ten people two
of them would be looking at you Annie
and also they go heroin and they nod
they were on straight heroin and then
what are you gonna find not that years
later they were Vietnam was basically
about heroin yeah they were just
bringing heroin back into by the [ __ ]
millions and this whole country that's
what I don't understand like when I see
those shows now somebody has to pay for
what they did to this country yeah Pablo
Escobar was a scumbag and the Medellin
Cartel was gum bags and they were small
time compared they were asshat stared
but who helped them grow yeah foreshores
and that's why those pictures like that
whole thing Tom Cruise made a movie
about American made and he got popped
it's a horrible movie but when you think
about what was going on it was just
horrible
you know then they started Sandinistas
whatever we're just bringing up coke
they cut them in they weren't even
having a war yeah they just cut them in
to bring a whole bring cocaine up our
own government flooded beat and then you
hear the Diego well you 320 metric tons
of cocaine were smuggled into our
country where's the war on drugs 300
metric tons that's 2,000 pounds of
[ __ ] ton of cocaine I can't snort
that [ __ ] in one year myself
we tried somebody had to be [ __ ]
snorted
but you look back at that conspiracy
right there that's not a conspiracy that
was something to ruin our country now no
forget having a teacher his name was
Fred Terra Nova and I remember he had
like a pseudo history class and I still
remember bumping into him on the street
one day and then telling me that the
Cubans are running cocaine and I'm like
what are you talking about he goes they
got it so sophisticated that the
Colombians are taking the coke to Cuba
when when Bush sat down the troops in 85
to Colombia they were going through the
jungles they couldn't find any lab yeah
they were long time they were processing
coke and go in Cuba they were taking the
coca leaves shipping them to Cuba
bringing in the [ __ ] ether from the
Russians which is even better than the
American ether they used that [ __ ] for
steroids and bball and [ __ ] like that
and they were shipping the cocaine out
of Cuba and Fidel Castro would get
800,000 per ship load and they were
sending two to three ships a day filled
with cocaine nobody ever mentioned
Fidel's name and any of those paperwork
but the story I'm getting to hear is
that because it killed me it destroyed
my life you know many people I seen from
my aides now on Facebook that have no
teeth got a [ __ ] up it was all cocaine
from the 80s bro and to think that our
own government brought that in shocks me
even as street-smart but I think I am
like I had I was always naive but that
not naive wouldn't it be what did we
smart for them to blow up Colombian drug
lords and Mexican drug lords I just do
the work themselves
yeah like blow them up on like movies
like Scarface for instance wouldn't a
bit wouldn't it be smart for them to
blow up something like Scarface and
movies like Scarface so that the people
think that it's them that are bringing
in all the coke and not really it's us
that's bringing it in you know I'm sad
for same thing with the Italian gangster
movies the conspiracy theory is that
those the people at the top whoever the
whatever you want to call them
they like pushing the Italian mobster
movies because everyone thinks it's the
Italians that are doing it when really
there were low-level there was a you
know our own people we're really the
ones at that
in charge in charge of exactly the
bankers and all bankers yeah but you
blow up the Italian so everyone thinks
aliens have all this power yeah
the Colombians have all this power and
they're doing it when really it's it's
us that are bringing an NDA the American
government is the there's a war on drugs
but we're bringing it look at heroin
right now with Afghanistan Productions
up 70% and now addictions up 70% so yeah
it could be even higher than that I mean
let's not even talk about the opioid
opioid epidemic in charge of putting
these pills in the street for sure and
then you hear the guy that basically
flooded the market with those pills has
now basically copyrighted the cure for
that that yeah it's the most gangster
[ __ ] ever dude he basically came he
caused a problem an epidemic of opiates
and now he's got the cure for it too
yeah I mean that's just gangster [ __ ] so
really what we're talking about
either it's true or it's [ __ ] it's
not true it's it really is just the
Colombians and the it's not but it's not
true yeah well of course right of course
but there's people that don't believe
any of that so either either our own
government is actually not managing and
controlling the drug flow between you
know internationally either they're not
or they are you know it and you know
there's people that actually believe
that our own government would would
never do anything like that right that's
what I'm saying that there's that's the
conspiracy like I grew up in Hudson
County New Jersey where it's very
politically corrupt and it didn't take
me too long to realize that ever that
was politics on the micro level all for
sure what was that the macro level you
know I went to the doctor three weeks
ago he knows all by the way we're
switching up that blood pressure
medication he was switching it up
so when I got home I gave my wife to
note and we looked at it and the one we
were on all of a sudden something's not
right with it
and I'm thinking to myself what happened
they stopped paying yes that pan that's
it they don't come in no more on Fridays
and give you an emblem exactly so now
start pushing this blood pressure
medication which you don't really know
what the [ __ ] they're giving you guys
know I have an uncle I call them up now
we have two conversations in the home
week you know he's had cancer for ten
years and he's still alive because he
just changed his diet and refused to go
to chemo you know he's 80 years old
mommy walks for the five miles every day
Monday through Friday
Griffin Park because he refused to get
the key mall the drugs the government
takes gave you say went to Mexico twice
in the ten years and got two blood
treatments or something like that he's
still alive
it's crazy the things that our own
government does to us it can see that
there's people that still and I loved
the United States of America of course I
love being a hell of everything about it
but that kind of [ __ ] always destroy any
ISM and it's so weird how it's like
anything else in life it's like being
Catholic and going alright I'm gonna go
to church today even though you know
they're a bunch of [ __ ] pedophile
right yeah we look at what we want to
look at and we don't look at what we
want to look at you know it's like when
in comedy it's like when somebody comes
up to you says this guy's a joke deep
but he's your best friend right what do
you do do you over do you stop being his
best friend or do you not discuss the
jokey thing that he's doing you know
you're always put on that [ __ ] spot
so yeah it's all I did the cronyism just
keeps going it's it's crazy really isn't
cronyism is just basically where these
guys just operate they make money off of
corruption and that's what we at the
highest levels on both sides man like
people think it's our zindies they're
falling for the tricks it's not these
guys all work together dude they I mean
dude if you looked into what happened in
Haiti man how much money was fleeced
from that country after the her after
the up
of the earthquake heartbreaking man
Haiti is a [ __ ]
because more the billion dollars of aid
was just taken out mysteriously by all
these people that you're supposedly love
it's unbelievable because they don't
look at you like a person they don't
look at us like a people
we're numbers we're resources listen
when all those things happen I really
try to be an American and help what I
picked my source of who I'm giving that
money to don't get I don't believe in it
anymore I don't I don't want to give
money to an organization with three of
the top guys have BMW convertible oh
yeah man do you little saying wonderful
I cry for the organization but the guys
got to come guys make it like the mercy
amps those are Nando's AB NGOs
non-governmental organizations that that
uh it sounds like they're human
you know humanitarian yeah but when you
figure out the percentage that they have
to give to be considered humanitarian
you laugh in their faces like I used to
sell you know as a comic you have
fundraising jobs might face the
fundraise for the cops in Seattle I
thought I was working for the police
department I was working for two [ __ ]
ex-cons that gave you a sticker if you
donate really nice benevolently yeah
when you're gonna call hi this is uh Sam
Tripoli I'm calling on behalf of
Glendale County police sorry Emma I'm
saying Glendale I don't care I'm falling
from Glendale police alarm because we're
doing a fundraiser you actually think
it's the cops it's three guys in the
hill in bar hair with a greasy place
with no air conditioning and they get
thirty percent of the take so you listen
we're gonna put our head together which
comes out in June if you advertising me
and put an ad in there what happens is
let's pretend you get broken into
you put a sticker on your glass and the
cops will know that you donate the cops
don't give oh that's all I do those cop
events for is hard so I can get out of
trouble yeah yeah
art is one thing the card is one thing I
live on those cars yeah I did I got a DA
would ya I got a DA one get your dog out
of my [ __ ] yeah this is my friendship I
got I got the real ones I got the [ __ ]
in I got a gold one two from Hoboken oh
I live for these things the [ __ ]
get-out-of-jail-free card
what's it say there yeah DEA we [ __ ]
around dog but that's not the thing you
do look at the NFL man that whole like
pink week cancer awareness the amount of
money that any organization gets for the
find research to cure cancer from the
NFL it's like 10% 10% it's some insane
number allegedly some insane number like
big I mean Michael Jordan was notorious
for it back in the day throw charity
events and like 20% went to the actual
you know to the cause there's this guy
and in Laos or Thailand who had a
foundation for kids that were were in
child sex trafficking and hit this his
story was he's the head of this
foundation I forget what the name of the
foundation is but his story is that he
saves all these children from sex
trafficking rings and in heat in
Thailand and he built this school to
help them rehab and you know educate
themselves and people just started
sending the money it's like [ __ ] like
who wouldn't want to donate to that this
guy is is breaking into these camps were
these where they're keeping these
children you know as slaves and he's
breaking about taking him through rivers
that's what the story is on the website
like he's taking all these children and
and he has profiles of each of the
children and they have their stories of
you know how their mom sold him to sex
trafficking and all this should all the
kids have different profiles of people
the website is touching to say the least
and people are just donating all sorts
of cash and you've built this big
compound and
it's a real compound with the school and
they really are educating these kids and
the kids are happy as [ __ ] right
happiest [ __ ] is then that interview and
they go man they they're super
appreciative they can't believe that
that they're getting an education for
free they can't believe it but then when
you look into it the guy wasn't these
kids weren't from child sex trafficking
they were just poor kids from you know
in the jungle you know in villages and
he would offer him education and and the
parents ago yes you know and take my
kids educate him but the kids had no
idea that there was this website and
they had this story that supposedly came
from their mouths that was saying that
you know that at six their mother sold
him it was all [ __ ] so this guy got
too greedy and this is how he got busted
he got too greedy he got a documentary
team to come out to film you know what
he was all about and to drum up more
business and to get more donations he
was getting all this money from people
although rich people all over the world
and the documentary crew they're the
ones who were going wait a minute
something ain't right here
something ain't right they figured it
out because these kids weren't from
child sex trafficking then they corner
the kids and they pull them aside and
they they made them read the story that
was on the website they had no idea the
story was that they didn't know no idea
they're like oh my they started all of
them start [ __ ] freaking out and
crying and like they thought oh my god
their life is ruined everyone thinks
they're a prostitute a child prostitute
if they weren't they were just regular
kids from you know the the country
country in Thailand and poor kids that
there were hell's going on right now my
god this guy got busted and he just
disappeared and they you know no one
knows where he's at
there's a couple that raised likes money
for this like marina this homeless
marine $100,000 yeah yeah are they
giving it to him yet a GoFundMe has to
give it to them because they live back
it but yeah they're going to court and
they're gonna be in trouble yeah yeah
they got to give away 90 grand of it
yeah I don't measure something saying
because I've listened with tinfoil hat
with the podcast what are you trying to
do what are you doing with I just like
the dude to be honest you pick a new
topic everywhere everyone
so last one last week the autopsy from
Bruce Lee came back they did on that
show but we were we work as a guy on HBO
that was fantastic
but this guy I thought of you I almost
called you they did not autopsy on ya
they read to opened up the case and
rills did again for fanny
and I watched him to see what they they
did the Whitney used to look all right
and when he used they said that
Whitney's didn't die cocaine what
happened was she did a couple bumps and
went into the shower and the shower was
so hot but since her body was numb she
didn't feel the heat and that's a really
killed Whitney Houston really yeah like
the holy [ __ ] stinks [ __ ] I can't the
fini they like i watch game the fini for
20 minutes I looked at my wife I go if
they don't mention cocaine I'll never
watch the show again and then they went
off on the cocaine how much coke he was
doing how they found that he went
through multiple rehabs in his heart so
now I pay attention because they at
least they tell the truth at least they
tell the truth he's not saying all this
channel this doctor how do you know
that's how do you know that's the truth
though because he would they were they
wouldn't have talked about the cocaine
they could have just said that he died
of a heart attack he went through
everything he goes from The Sopranos
they found that how many rehabs you gone
through oh he was notorious all during
sat like he would just disappear
banging Jim Sopranos yeah yeah the guy
that was in true oh man yeah yeah couple
years ago four years ago but it's crazy
how this guy started talking about how
he would do no shows on the soprano you
had the four days no show no here no
nothing and he would come back and he
would pay for the days off he would pay
the days to the staff missing and then
he would fly in sushi and different food
and then they apologize them two weeks
laying it but the moral the story is
that he's going hard in the paint yep
all everybody knew that everybody knew
that because of that I started paying
attention to the show more and a couple
cuz you brought me under talk about what
what happened nicely so what they say
happened and I always
because my conspiracy theory was what he
told him he was doing into the dragon he
was switching governments and they that
would cut off their money laundering
because they were money laundering
through his movies all those time movies
there was just one dish out all those in
Thailand and it was Raymond chow and
it's really funny that after an olden
harvest Golden Harvest after Raymond
chow and Bruce Lee died Raymond chow
became a big producer in the United
States even produced in Charles Bronson
movies so I always thought there was
some type of conspiracy is something
like that you know how he died how it
was really hash like there was no
internet back then guys yeah so you died
in China too until the bug got here yeah
for us to find out about Bruce Lee
nobody knew then one day on the streets
people started talking about it we went
into Chinatown and got the newspaper
from China and they showed you the
pictures of him in the casket but it
wasn't there's no internet there was no
encyclopedia and what he talks about is
he died from a cortisol addiction that
nobody knew about what cortisol cool
will you shooting you when you have play
oh yeah cortisol cortisol his own hitted
so he heard his back and he was shooting
on a cortisone and because cortisone
does something this side effects the
cortisone he never went off the
cortisone he never went off like that
during into the Dragon he got to the
lightest he ever was he was like 123 is
something like that they were worried
about it so he broke it down he goes and
then when he did that aspirin Deanna
leezak he had so much cortisol in his
blood
bah-bah-bah it was death by misadventure
you know I'm saying he's so there's
nothing shady behind it no it was
something that he had developed years
earlier something with that
there's a side effect the cortisol and
he was having mental lapses at the end
he was forgetting [ __ ] yeah you know
what what if your first theory was
actually correct like he was murdered by
the Chinese triads which is a conspiracy
there would have and that's what you
thought at first if that was true
wouldn't it make sense to put out a
documentary to distract from that and
just say yeah we did some tests on his
blood he died of cortisol you know what
I mean it I mean listen II think first
off it's a forty five-year-old court
yeah
whatever document well you guys don't
know it's like listen and I'll tell you
this right now and we'll wrap it up just
so you know at the age of sixteen I
found out everything about my life and
my father who was I was always told to
either a drug died of a heart attack
what happened was he was the first Cuban
committeeman and you didn't see New
Jersey so they were up playing them at
the time when you landed from Cuba in
Miami there was billboards that said
come to you in the city there's life for
Cubans there so it became the second
biggest highest population for Cubans
along the way my father had a business
he had two businesses and this is way
pre Castro
so he had he was a committee man from
like 56 to 66 until he died he was on
some board and when he died he died of a
cocaine overdose he died of a heroin he
thought he was doing coke but somebody
gave heroin killed him instantly and all
that got covered up dude
they made my mother send him to Cuba and
my father is buried in Cuba so when I I
didn't find this out till I got older
like why would my mother send my father
[ __ ]
Cuba like it just didn't make sense and
in those days it wasn't like you could
just call United so my mother went with
him all the way to Mexico and then in
Mexico they ship into Cuban and his
family picked them up so my mother could
never collect the insurance policy that
he left for me he left me a Prudential
insurance policy
it was never signed by the county
coroner my father's death is still the
karlon never sounded my father was a
nobody
yeah he was a nobody so imagine what
do like again we're talking about this
[ __ ] that you know he was a nobody why
would they cover it up right so till
this day
Prudential wants me to go to Cuba dig
him up for them to give me any money
like in 1900 they should like in 1980
that was the deal
for us to go to Cuba reanalyze the bones
and see if it was him so after that how
do you think I felt about governments in
here like that like I don't believe in
nothing yeah see that's what it's all
about that was my question everything
that's what I always say do question
everything that's really all we do we
just have fun you question it when we're
wrong a lot you know
we're wrong a lot but it's really tough
it's better than just going along with
God that's my whole thing man it's just
like you watch the news they lie to you
all the time all day launch day listen
were the best thing about podcasters
listen to what happened in podcast
it destroyed Comedy Central that
credibility became [ __ ] you guys
have been hiding the real comics from us
for the last ten years since you've been
[ __ ] since 1992 and 91 that you've
been in business right you've been
giving us hand-selected County that you
guys like not the animals Doug yeah
they lost so crazy now that's why now
even as a musician fan of music you
gotta think to yourself was kiss really
the best band that was out there or will
kiss what they shoved down my throat
exactly you know that's how I grew up
the biggest kiss fan of all time but but
man if they were an Illuminati operation
they're perfect look what look at look
at the the four characters that they're
they're like the Illuminati really the
Illuminati comes from you know ancient
Babylon and and ancient Egypt and all
that in the bloodlines right so you look
at the the cat Peter Criss Egyptians
worshipped cats and then you looked at
Ace Frehley space look what the Nazis
did when they formed NASA and gave us
the fake moon missions right they keep
promoting space and the
gene Simmons the [ __ ] Beeman when you
look into the Illuminati there they are
Bartolo worshipping Lucifer right yeah
and then Paul Stanley is there and he's
Paul Stanley that's the you know that's
the the feminism in men right there
so they got four gigantic characters
that are powerful in the Illuminati
movement that's just you know that's
just me getting crazy that's just me
getting crazy but you brought it up he
said what if kiss wasn't the best better
scare what if the car it's what you sold
me so yeah I've always quite listening I
love being a Catholic but I think as I'm
at the age of 10 my question right so
cool right why isn't nun hitting me yeah
why are why are there bishops and car
hit me love yeah and whatever you know
so that's why they all [ __ ] kids you
know what what's up I know but nobody
does the jail no not about [ __ ] the
kids you know I didn't know that like
even the Mormon Church over 70% of
Sunset Boulevard yeah something crazy
something crazy about Scientology I read
years ago yeah that the more that's why
sighs you know Mormons orbit older what
do you know a Donald Trump when he got
elected he went to Utah and he talked to
the Church of the Mormons to kiss the
ring like they're very powerful and if
they're very much of an outside power
source compared to what goes on in
Hollywood you know I mean in uh
Washington DC they say if these big
trials are gonna happen you know that
they keep talking about what Q anonymous
and all that stuff which is this guy who
gives information out to people because
you can't get it on normal on networks
but he basically says that's where a lot
of judges are gonna come from Utah and
Mormons like Trump had no yeah crazy
[ __ ] man I love it though dude I love it
and you know what I love I know we're
wrong dude but we're right a lot too and
the thing is that nobody keeps score
that's the whole thing like nobody wants
to
truth yeah you know in that famous movie
you don't want the truth is you really
can't handle the truth right you know
what I love doing coke I didn't want to
know that our own government was pushing
it on the streets you know I loved to
smokin coke I didn't know that the CIA
was putting it on [ __ ] the streets of
Compton in black neighborhoods to make
them even weaker than what they were
I'll never forget read an article in
time that the man with the Golden Gun
was being hidden Cuba some guy I forget
what his name was in the 70s that was
escaping from the United States and I
remember them saying at that time I had
a teacher mr. t and him gone for years
the Russians have been selling coke it's
all communist and I walk and I remember
saying why would communist wanna sell
coke in the United States he goes this
it makes them a lot easier to take over
when they come over and they put the
guns up and we put up bags of kilos
they're gonna throw the guns open the
egg bucket so made sense all this [ __ ] I
learned over the years it's just people
don't really want to know there was a
fake moon landing you know you you
listen to the stories now how bad the
country was in shape and he had some to
be pro-american so they thought about
going to the moon and landing but the
wind wasn't blowing the right direction
I [ __ ] up the flag you know same no I
never do and the whole thing isn't to
get everybody to grab everything all the
time it's like it's like when when
there's a murder and there's really no
evidence at first detective you know a
group of detectives will come up with
every possible scenario at every part no
matter how ridiculous it is if it's
somehow possible it's a scenario and
they got all they line up all their
scenarios and all their suspects and
then one by one they eliminate eliminate
them doesn't mean that every scenario is
correct it can't be it's impossible that
error every sinner but you come up with
every possible angle so that's all we do
when something happens like anytime a
celebrity is killed a conspiracy
theorist is gonna have questions you're
gonna have the official story that you
read on on your phone when you're taking
a [ __ ] like oh my god you know who died
and you read it
your phone and then the police confirmed
that it was a suicide you know what I
mean are you gonna believe that you read
it on your phone you're taking a [ __ ]
it's on your iPhone it's on CNN it's on
the Washington Post so-and-so died
police confirm it was a suicide they
confirmed with that goddamn quick are
you gonna believe that maybe you do
believe it maybe it's true but a
detective wouldn't just believe that
[ __ ] a detective would start looking
into it and putting uh you know coming
up with as many different scenarios as
possible
and putting together clues that's what
that's what you do you just don't read
your iPhone and just believe that should
confirm a police confirm that it was a
suicide okay that's it but that's it
that's it it's a suicide so out on my
[ __ ] phone you know but then there's
all this great these crazy little things
that are going on around that certain
suicide that you're like wait a minute
[ __ ] you know there's a lot of
crazy fishy [ __ ] going on around here
and to be to be ridiculed for
questioning something that you read on
your [ __ ] phone while you were taking
a [ __ ] questioning your ridiculed your
ridiculed I'll tell you what one thing
about if it ever comes out you ever find
out that I committed suicide I'll
[ __ ] do backflips in my [ __ ] grave
if you start getting on Instagram saying
oh we lost another good one yeah I know
two drugs I will be pissed off if
anybody wrote that [ __ ] because if it
comes out that I committed suicide how
is [ __ ] murder because I I ain't
committing suicide you know what I mean
so it's people think it's disrespectful
to question you have that funny they
think it's disrespectful when someone
comes out and you know someone commits
suicide and the car you read it on your
phone cop said cop said that was a
suicide they ruled it a suicide to
question that and to get ridiculed is
disgusting that's disgusting you know
what I mean if someone if like you found
out that someone you you love close to
you and you found out just like everyone
else they committed suicide and you
[ __ ] all you knew is what you [ __ ]
read on your phone and the cops and then
then someone came up you say hey dude
what do you want to hear it oh what'd
you say
it's too soon yes the 3d8 it was assumed
witness building and maybe eight years
ago that I knew the kid yeah until this
day I always knew that something was
wrong and two years is it disrespectful
to go wait a minute maybe it wasn't a
suit yeah I don't get that I don't get
why accepting the official narrative of
people respect their their their family
I think the family would want to know
who some fishy shits going on the best
rise they killed Osama bin Laden but
they threw his body off the ship oh yeah
oh yeah see it exactly does this come on
you all that come on come on autopsy
yeah the Vegas [ __ ] there's so much it's
just too much that if you get caught up
in it and you start doubting you will go
crazy so that's what you guys know basis
of all you always gotta have the foot on
the ground right you always gotta have
that and it's like the way I see
conspiracies is no different than the
person who's always watching MSNBC you
know Christopher Titus is a wonderful
comedian I think he's a killer he put
out that like he think Rachel Maddow for
teaching him more about like US history
and I'm not saying anything bad about
that but he obviously watches MSNBC all
the time that's where he gets his news I
just like to investigate I just like to
learn to see what's going on and then
kind of be like oh here's a pattern and
it's kind of in it I don't think I'm
gonna change anything the only thing
that I do after I learn all this is how
I interact with people in the world how
do I treat people okay I try to treat
people with love respect when John
McCain dies I don't run around talking
about what a war hero he is because
that's not the truth man and there's a
lot of shady [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] he put a lot of our sons
and daughters in very bad harm's way
it's just a fact man and I'm gonna get
some [ __ ] about that and I'll ah hey man
I love you that's what I'll stand by it
man that's what the best is you know I
remember him that we have a voice now
yeah we have a voice now you don't have
to sit at home alone you know what [ __ ]
you [ __ ] that's not what
happened I mean actually knucklehead
something you and my brother you're
going on
doing some dates together which I'm
proud of you I'm probably from [ __ ]
Commission impressed right man I'm yeah
oh you you're all these guys have been
around comedy for so long and they get
it and people say I can't believe please
don't count me well he's been around it
for six years he watches every special
on Netflix after a while you gotta give
it a chance
yeah Eddie's been around it I stood my
Matty going on stage 2001 2001 Wow
so bombing oh but he got it he got you a
great dude you're doing great and that's
all that matters thank you where's your
next date you [ __ ] saying we're here
I know
it's September 14 15 that we're at the
corner comedy club in Niagara Falls
Canada it's at the corner comedy club
calm is this Friday says yeah we've sold
a bunch of tickets man so this writer
said yeah yeah you know a girl falls and
I'm doing a seminar Saturday day in
Niagara Falls to jujitsu school out
there get on my Instagram for the
details that's at Eddie Bravo Tempe well
the dates you doing it's in for Hannah
so we're also do i they're on my website
sam tripoli calm we're also doing
philadelphia and october october 12
october 12th and then the 14th of funny
bone in syracuse yep so October 12 in
Philly October 14 so we're doing Friday
in a Sunday that's Saturday and doing a
seminar in Bethlehem but and then we're
going out to the following month were in
November and Austin neva 4th so what do
you guys gonna onstage just do a podcast
or no to two guys that would stand up we
are we do about an hour of stand-up and
then we do about 30 to 45 minutes of Q&A
with the crowd there's usually four of
us it's me Sam Ryan who's his co-host on
the 10% of my love is a great foil hat
podcast yeah awesome his co-host Ryan
off the grid ride he's he's usually with
us and we have another guy Trez malla
who he could bring out when financially
it makes sense you know ii mean so
there's four of us but some a lot of
times when we go on the road is just
gonna be me and Sam just for financial
purposes and then we'll
a local comedian but uh it's so much fun
though damn fun to have a to have a
whole crowd
that's at least tower seven and over you
know what I mean if they're all on Tower
seven it's a lot easier to talk to him
you know what I mean because if I had a
crowd that was half people that believed
Hillary Clinton was a good person dude
I'd be bombing it's not gonna be a good
night so that's how 10 foil hat comedy
came about we you know I did a couple
shows with Sam you know random shows at
the Comedy Store with a comedy chaos and
it just man I got I got to conspiracy to
quick and it just didn't flow right the
first couple shows and I called up Sam
one night and I said dude can we do it a
tinfoil hat [ __ ] comedy show where
it's just nothing but people that are at
least at Tower 7 if you're at least the
tower 7 then [ __ ] how much fun with that
yeah so that's what we started doing
tinfoil hat comedy and and it's it's
been we went to San Francisco and
Sacramento and [ __ ] smashed it there
was crazy it was it was [ __ ] crazy
we get to San Francisco half an hour
before the show it looks like it's 1/4
filled and then we went backstage and
like you know what no one showed up no
big deal no big deal no one showed up
it's all good you know we're just gonna
go out there and there's [ __ ] there's
a hundred people so what it's a hundred
people that's beautiful
but we went out by the than five minutes
before the show started went out and
took a look again and it was [ __ ]
ugly and I went upstairs and I tell Sam
you're not gonna believe this because
what I go dude all of a sudden it's
[ __ ] packed and he goes no we went
out to Mike holy [ __ ] that was that's
that's only new that maybe there's a
chance that we could do this on the road
we were in San Francisco making fun of
Obama and people are going crazy yeah
I'm like all that in San Francisco
that's a crazy dude yeah it's very
powerful and then in Sacramento which is
cool I love I love doing comedy in front
of your crowd when I opened up for you a
couple of times because it's just all
Mexicans and it's all Latin they're not
necessarily conspiracy theorists they're
just Mexicans I love just going up and
doing Mexican like non conspiracy theory
could comment
not all my my comedy is about conspiracy
theories I talk about have dick jokes
and fart jokes and [ __ ] like that but um
Sacramento it was all conspiracy it was
a conspiracy crowd but they were all
Mexican so it was the Sacramento show
was [ __ ] insane we had so much fun
it's just a combo of Mexicans and
conspirators were great mr. [ __ ] hoes
I'm happy you stopped in today you know
I mean both I love you too it's one of
my favorite shows to do I walk it's
probably sold out already comedy shows
always sold that I'm doing Tuesday yeah
I hate bothering you guys I don't love
her you call me you fine I hate it you
don't bother me
it's just I just don't know what I could
be there but all good yeah the
guaranteed sold-out show Russell Peters
job Joe Rogan's always Romans on it's a
great feel Vaughn yeah this would be Tom
Segura Ari
Duncan thank you again I love you beyond
what amazes to the floor hi come on it's
this wall this weekend we don't know
what Monday and Thursday for the podcast
yeah to podcasting yeah yeah Sam all the
best
I love you Bob least or family we've
been together 20 years then I had a
great time we had him at the Dodger game
Monday night with the kids the Dodger
game I was the budget we were so high so
yeah this is no joke
I have a real legit fear of heights and
no seats the highest Dodger like I felt
like the whole time I had that fear
running through my blood
I felt like I was gonna fall off and my
son's with me and I'm looking over at my
son and I just want to grab him but
there's no way you look there's no way
we could fall off but we were pretty
goddamn high and the whole time I'm
afraid of falling off I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] sad we took pictures we have kids
we just took a bit much spin you know
we're so when I apply put me and he be
with our families in the Dodger game and
all we got and I was like that's great
as well
but then you always got people I knew
you couldn't got better seats yeah it's
not about the better seats it's just
about being together with your family hi
yeah we gotta go lower them oh yeah I
could call sit right behind the Dodgers
but I don't want to do that with not
with five-year-olds yeah I want to
attract this Lisa type job as we did we
gotta got it one of us from Liverpool
yeah in the picture with us we ate you
know and I'm gonna try this five home
games left I'm gonna try to go to one
more to expect my phone call I love you
saying thank you I love you too I want
to thank Eddie and Sanford stopping them
but most importantly listen to me
23andme is a DNA testing service that
could offer insights into your ancestry
health wellness and traits the bitter
taste report versus too salty reports
DNA play a role in determining what your
food preferences from sweet to salty too
bitter 23andme health an ancestry
service includes reports on how your DNA
can influence your weight your sleep
quality your caffeine intake sense of
taste whether you're likely to be
lactose intolerant and more it's easy to
do you just spit into a tube provided by
23andme and you mail you saliva sample
back to the lab to be analyzed I'll tell
you what I did it I did it about a year
ago that's why when they contacted me I
was all over it and I learned a lot from
where I was from and how they found this
DNA from chickens that the Chinese had
you know I'm African from the north tip
of Spain up there I'm also American
Indian I'm also a little Chinese and if
I'm a little Russian Jewish you know all
these things are very interesting to
find out you know so what I would do if
I was you guys I mean the lactose and
child reports shed insights into how
your genetics may affect your ability to
digest dairy products stuff like that
just simple stuff like that and now when
I got sick a couple months ago I
eliminated dairy and boom I went on the
reports a couple weeks ago and that's
what it was that I was susceptible to
that and pasta and all that stuff and
like maple men might tell you guys I was
- maple syrup now even when I have the
Lego waffles - the wheat and I put the
sugarless syrup on it I still get sick
on it this told me all this stuff on the
report
so listen besides telling you where
you're from and who you are and who
you're a piece of this 23andme is the
way to go so do me a favor
what are your 23andme health and
ancestry service at 23andme calm again
23andme calm slash Church CH you are CH
that's the number 23andme
slash church.com okay no no so it's
23andme
dot-com slash Church that's the way you
go okay so listen find out who you are
and what's going on and you'll be fine
alright take a chance Columbus did I
don't know a lot of user scared to find
out who you really are you might find
that your uncle your cousin but who
cares
take a chance anyway football season is
in full effect whether it's college or
the pros you're rockin and rollin I know
that you got a guy that knows a guy what
happens one day when the guy skips on
you and now you don't get you a little
$80 or you're 180 and you need that
money that's why me I tell my family
here from the church to go with my
bookie why because they're tremendous
the truth is I don't know who's gonna
win but if you think you know you gotta
check out my bookie remember when you
it's not what you're betting on this is
important that who you're betting with
that's why I always tell people to you
to bet with my bookie trust me they're
the best around [ __ ] flat period
they've been in business for years they
got great reviews online and their
mobile site is easy to use I'd only
recommend the service to you guys that's
been good to me that's why I'm urging
you right now to go to my bookie you
know why because they pay when you win
plain and simple they got game live
betting the most rewarding player perks
in the business and for your fantasy
guys out there you can even bet the over
and under on how many fantasy points a
players for each game how are you gonna
get that action anywhere else No
we're but my bookie so do me a favor
join today right now it's it's Monday
morning you saying that your desk you're
scratching your balls you don't know
yeah well I like Monday but listen it
all starts with making money wailing
watch the game for what to eat popcorn
and waste your time going right now join
my bookie and will match your deposit
dollar for dollar you put in two dollars
they give you two now so now you have
four hours where you gonna get that
tight passion cuz that's how uncle Joey
takes care what you do is go to my
bookie and use promo code Church CH you
are CH to activate the offer visit my
bookie online today
that's my bookie my B oh okay I and
don't forget to use the promo code
Church CH you are CH when creating your
account to claim up to a thousand
dollars in free play plain and simple
with my bookie you play you win you get
paid who's [ __ ] better than you
I want to tank thank 23andme I want to
thank my bookie I want to thank Santa
Polly I want to thank Eddie Bravo you
guys know I'm both and how they're gonna
hold them I want to thank my main man
the [ __ ] but most importantly
you guys you're my family
and again I'll see you guys right now
the only tickets available
alright Foxwoods casino in Connecticut
so hopefully I'll see you guys there
this month if you're from the east coast
I love you [ __ ] have a great
week there's a great way to start the
week stay black kick this [ __ ] meal
Lee